Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. This episode is sponsored by our good friends at Sky, all because their new Sky original film, Lee, is available from the 13th of September only in cinemas. Now, Lee charts the life of one of the most remarkable photographers of the Second World War, Lee Miller. And that's the person we're going to be talking about in today's episode. It was her photographs of Dachau and her photographs from across the ruins of the Third Reich, Tom, that
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先看以及加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本期节目由我们的老朋友 Sky 赞助，因为他们全新的 Sky 原创电影《李》将于 9 月 13 日起在各大影院上映。现在，这部电影讲述了第二次世界大战中最杰出的摄影师之一——李·米勒的一生。这也是我们在今天的节目中要聊的人物。正是她拍摄的达豪集中营的照片，以及她拍摄的横跨整个第三帝国废墟的照片，汤姆，
brought home the horrors of the conflict to the British and American public. So Kate Winslet plays Lee, but it is kind of an amazingly A-list cast all round. So there's Andy Samberg, Alexander Skarsgård, Marielle Cotillard, Josh O'Connor, Andrea Rysborough, all starring it alongside her. Well, Tom, as you know, I've always been really fascinated by Lee Miller as a character, because I often think that without photographs like the ones that she took, would the world have been able to come to terms with what was happening and understand what was happening in the concentration camps in quite the same way? Yeah, it explores that, explores other aspects of the Second World War,
将这场冲突的残酷真相展现在了英国和美国公众面前。片中由凯特·温丝莱特饰演李，但周围的演员阵容可以说是全明星级别的。安迪·萨姆伯格、亚历山大·斯卡斯加德、玛丽昂·歌迪亚、乔什·奥康纳、安德烈·赖斯伯勒都在片中与她同台飙戏。汤姆，如你所知，我一直对李·米勒这个人物非常着迷，因为我常常觉得，如果没有她拍下的那些照片，世界能够真正正视并理解集中营里发生的事情吗？是的，电影探讨了这一点，也探讨了第二次世界大战的其他方面，
the relationship of photography to conflict and to horror. And I mean, it's a real kind of prestige drama, a very serious story on one level, but also thrilling. I really loved it. Lee is out in cinemas from Friday the 13th of September and you can go to sky.com to find out more. These are pictures of a nation at war. They are honest pictures,
探讨了摄影与冲突以及恐怖之间的关系。而且，这是一部真正意义上的大制作正剧，表面上是一个非常严肃的故事，但同时又惊心动魄。我真的很喜欢这部电影。《李》将于 9 月 13 日星期五在各大影院上映，你可以访问 sky.com 了解更多信息。这些是处于战争中的国家的照片。它们是诚实的照片，
routine scenes to those of us who have reported Britain's ordeal by fire and high explosive. These Englishmen have bought survival with their tender-roofed old buildings, with their bodies and their nerves. This little book offers you a glimpse of their battle. Somehow they are able to fight down their fears each night, to go to work each morning. So that was the legendary CBS war correspondent, Ed Murrow, in the introduction to his book, Grim Glory, Pictures of Britain Under Fire. And it was a book that was designed, essentially designed as pro-British propaganda in the Second World War, showing the American public how Britain was
对于我们这些报道过英国战火与高爆炸弹苦难的人来说，这些都是日常场景。这些英国人以他们残破的古老建筑、用他们的血肉之躯和坚强的神经换取了生存。这本小册子让你得以一窥他们的战斗。不知为何，他们每晚都能克制恐惧，每天清晨照常去上班。刚才那是传奇的 CBS 战地记者爱德华·默罗为其著作《残酷的荣耀：战火下的英国风光》所作的序言。这本书基本上是作为二战期间的亲英宣传品而设计的，向美国公众展示了英国在
carrying on during the Blitz. But Dominic, the real interest of that book isn't the deathless prose, which I just read, I think, very beautifully. But the pictures, and specifically, perhaps, the identity of the woman who took those pictures which is the great photographer lee miller yes so some listeners may not have heard of lee miller but i'm guessing that almost all of them will have seen her pictures whether they know it or not so the most famous ones probably the most infamous i suppose are the pictures she took of dachau when Dachau was liberated. So that's the sort of late April 1945. But she also took, there's a very famous photograph of a GI on Hitler's bed in his apartment in Munich reading a copy of Mein Kampf that went around the world.
闪电战期间是如何坚持下来的。但多米尼克，这本书真正的吸引力不在于我刚刚非常优美地朗读出来的那些不朽散文，而在于照片，尤其是拍摄这些照片的女性身份——也就是伟大的摄影师李·米勒。是的，有些听众可能没听说过李·米勒，但我猜他们几乎所有人都看过她的照片，无论他们是否知道。其中最著名的，或者说最声名狼藉的，大概是达豪集中营解放时她拍下的那些照片。那是1945年4月下旬左右。但她还拍过一张非常著名的照片，一个美国士兵在慕尼黑希特勒公寓的床上看《我的奋斗》，这张照片传遍了全世界。
And there's probably an even more famous picture now of Lee Miller herself in Hitler's bath. Tom, you must have seen that picture. I have, yeah. Tremendous image. I've always been really interested in Lee Miller. I have a sort of stash of old magazines from the 1940s at the back of my office.
现在可能还有一张更著名的照片，是李·米勒本人坐在希特勒的浴缸里。汤姆，你一定看过那张照片。我看过，是的。非常震撼的影像。我一直对李·米勒很感兴趣。我办公室的后面藏着一堆20世纪40年代的旧杂志。
And a lot of them have Lee Miller photographs. And I've always been interested in her because she's a pioneering female photographer, because she's a great link between the world of the kind of 1920s 1930s artistic avant-garde you know i love the avant-garde tom i know you do you love a bit of surrealism love it all over it i mean actually i'm quite a surrealist kind of person i know you are i think i'd fit into that milieu beautifully lobster telephones all of that yeah exactly
其中很多都有李·米勒的照片。我一直对她很感兴趣，因为她是一位先锋女性摄影师，因为她是20世纪20年代到30年代艺术前卫派世界之间的一座伟大桥梁。你知道我很喜欢前卫派，汤姆。我知道你喜欢，你挺喜欢超现实主义的，爱不释手。其实我本人就是个挺超现实主义的人。我知道你是，我觉得我能完美融入那种氛围。龙虾电话，诸如此类。对，没错。
but also her experiences in the war are pretty extraordinary so she's a great character yeah so i'll put my hand up i only had the vaguest sense of her so i knew about the photos she took of the holocaust and of her in the bath and a vague sense that she's kind of hanging out with man ray and picasso and cocteau in paris leading her best American expat life there. But as research for this, I've done two things, Dominic. So I went yesterday to Goldhanger Towers, where Gary Lineker has had a private cinema built for himself. Really? Yeah. Who goes to that? You, Alan Shearer, Alistair Campbell. Yeah, we're all hanging out there. Oh my God. I'm never invited. And obviously Theo was there with the popcorn.
但她在战争中的经历也非常非凡，所以她是一个很棒的人物。好吧，我坦白，我对她只有最模糊的了解：我知道她拍过关于大屠杀的照片，知道她在浴缸里的照片，还有一种模糊的印象，就是她在巴黎和曼·雷、毕加索、科克托等人鬼混，过着她最好的美国外派人员生活。但为了做这期节目的研究，多米尼克，我做了两件事。昨天我去了黄金挂楼，加里·莱因克尔在那里为自己建了一个私人电影院。真的吗？对。谁去那种地方？你、阿兰·希勒、阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔。对，我们都在那儿闲晃。天哪。我从来没被邀请过。显然特奥也在那儿分发爆米花。
Yeah. Tabby was serving out ice cream. Had a wonderful time. Oh, I'm so jealous. And they were screening a new film about Lee Miller, which stars Kate Winslet. Really? Who puts in fantastic performance. Because actually, you know, she looks quite like Lee Miller.
对，塔比在分发冰激凌。度过了一段美好的时光。哦，我太嫉妒了。他们在那里放映了一部关于李·米勒的新电影，主演是凯特·温丝莱特。真的吗？她的表演棒极了。因为事实上，你知道，她长得挺像李·米勒的。
Okay. So that taught me all kinds of things I didn't know. So I didn't know that she ended up in a farm in Sussex And also I didn't know that she was married to Alexander Skarsgård Which was a pleasant surprise to discover Yeah, you must have been excited by that Who has a very good English accent Yeah
好吧。这让我知道了各种我不知道的事情。比如我不知道她最后在萨塞克斯郡的一个农场落脚。而且我也不知道她嫁给了亚历山大·斯卡斯加德。这是一个惊喜的发现。是的，你对此一定很兴奋。他有着非常好的英国口音。
Which I hadn't realised And then I came back from watching that And I went into the Bodleian And I made copious notes Yeah So I now feel that I am ready to go head to head with you So you're full of I'm full of Lee Miller facts.
这一点我之前没意识到。然后我看完电影回来，去了博德利图书馆，做了大量的笔记。是的。所以我现在觉得我可以去跟你正面对决了。所以你满脑子都是……我满脑子都是关于李·米勒的事实。
You're full of interesting anecdotes that aren't true. Well, this is what I want to find out. I want to find out what, you know, what's kind of accurate in the film, what's accurate in Wikipedia. I'm suspecting the film is more accurate than Wikipedia, but whatever. Take it away, Dominic. Okay. So the story of Lee Miller.
你满脑子都是不真实的有趣轶事。好吧，这正是我要查明的。我想弄清楚电影里哪些是准确的，维基百科上哪些是准确的。我猜电影比维基百科更准确，不过随便啦。开始吧，多米尼克。好吧。那么关于李·米勒的故事。
So she's born, Tom, I'm very pleased to say, in Poughkeepsie, New York. I mean, that is ridiculous spelling, isn't it? I thought it was Poughkeepsie. I don't know. Why can't they have sensible spelling in America, like Worcester? Yeah, like Gloucester. Yeah, exactly. They let themselves down there.
汤姆，我非常高兴地宣布，她出生在纽约州波基普西。这个拼写太荒谬了，对吧？我一直以为是 P-o-u-g-h 开头的。我不知道。为什么美国不能像伍斯特那样有合理的拼写呢？对，就像格洛斯特。对，没错。他们在那里让人失望了。
Anyway, she's born there in 1907. So that's in, I think, the Hudson Valley. Her father, Theodore Miller. Tom, brilliantly, he's descended from one of the Hessians who fought for the legitimate authorities at the end of the 18th century against the tax chiefs. So he's in favour of paying tax. Definitely.
不管怎样，她于1907年出生在那里。我想那是在哈德逊河谷。她的父亲，西奥多·米勒。汤姆，绝妙的是，他是18世纪末为合法当局反对税务长官而战的黑森雇佣兵的后代。所以他是赞成纳税的。绝对的。
He's the work superintendent at a factory. He's a great tinkerer. And in fact, they're a family of tinkerers. Tinkerers, not tinkers. Yeah, exactly. They're definitely not tinkers. Selling pots and pans from door to door. No, they're a family of tinkerers so as a girl tinkerers not tinkers yeah yeah exactly they're definitely not tinkers selling pots and pans from door to door no they're not so um one thing we know about her there's a biography of her by her um her son anthony penrose that sort of goes into
他是工厂的工场主管。他是个超级喜欢动手修理东西的人。事实上，他们一家都是爱动手修理东西的人。是修补匠，不是流浪汉。对，没错。他们绝对不是流浪汉。挨家挨户兜售锅碗瓢盆那种。不，他们是一家人，喜欢动手修理东西，所以作为一个女孩——修补匠，不是流浪汉。对，没错。他们绝对不是流浪汉，挨家挨户兜售锅碗瓢盆那种。不，他们不是。所以呢，我们对她了解的一点是，她儿子安东尼·彭罗斯为她写过一本传记，里面详细讲述了她的生平。所以，她非常迷恋化学套装，
the details of her life so um she was a great enthusiast for a chemistry set and she's tinkering away with their chemistry set while her father has built a dark room under the stairs and his big love is photography so obviously from a very early age she's surrounded by cameras she loves all this you know they love messing around with little machines and stuff but actually tom there's a there's quite a dark shadow over her childhood i was quite shocked to read this very very, very dark, isn't it? She went to stay with family friends in Brooklyn when she was seven. And the son of these family friends abused her. And she got back to Poughkeepsie. And she was infected with venereal disease.
当她父亲在楼梯底下建了一个暗室时，她一直在用化学套装捣鼓，而他的挚爱是摄影。所以很显然，从很小的时候起，她就被相机包围着，她喜欢这一切，你知道的，他们喜欢摆弄小机器之类的东西。但事实上，汤姆，她的童年有着相当黑暗的阴影。我读到这里时感到非常震惊。非常，非常黑暗，不是吗？她七岁时去布鲁克林探访家庭朋友。这些朋友的儿子虐待了她。等她回到波基普西时，她感染了性病。
And the only treatment in those days, pre-penicillin, was they had to sort of douse her with dichloride of mercury. And this apparently was very traumatic. When she was seven years old. This was very traumatic. And her parents then sent her to a psychiatrist. And in the biography by her son, he says that the psychiatrist basically went out of his way to say to her, sex and love are two totally different things. You know, you can completely disassociate them. them and i don't think you have to be too much of a kind of amateur psychologist to think that this
在那个没有青霉素的年代，唯一的治疗方法就是用二氯化汞冲洗她的身体。据说这非常痛苦。在她七岁的时候。这非常痛苦。她的父母随后把她送去看了精神科医生。在她儿子的传记中，他提到这位精神科医生基本上不遗余力地对她讲：性和爱是完全不同的两件事。你知道的，你可以把它们完全剥离。我不认为你必须具备多少业余心理学知识，就能看出这
had an impact on the way she thought about personal relationships as we will see because she ends up being somebody who does completely disassociate sex and love but i suppose dominic also this is the era where freud's ideas are starting to be popularized psychoanalysis is becoming very mainstream and so i suppose she will grow up in that milieu when she in particularly in paris where she ends up yeah definitely all of these ideas are very very current yes absolutely she's a very wayward child in some ways she's always she's not clearly bright but she's always been kicked out of various private schools in new york in 1925 so when she's a teenager one of her teachers who's actually a polish woman who teaches french she's taking a shine to lee and she
对她看待个人关系的方式产生了影响，正如我们后面将看到的，她最终成为了一个完全将性与爱剥离开来的人。但我想多米尼克，这也是弗洛伊德的思想开始普及的时代，精神分析变得非常主流，所以我想她在那种环境中长大，尤其是在她最后待过的巴黎。是的，绝对的，所有这些想法都非常非常普遍。没错，她在某些方面是一个非常任性的孩子，她总是——她显然很聪明，但她总是在纽约的各种私立学校被开除。1925年，当她还是个青少年时，她的一个老师（实际上是一个教法语的波兰女性）看中了李，并
says i'll take you to paris for the summer and she goes to paris she absolutely falls in love with i mean this is kind of paris in its heyday really yeah between the wars painters mom march or all that all that stuff exactly and she actually then decides she's going to stay and she stays for a year she studies theater i like to think of her doing a lot of mime. Yes. At a theatre that had been co-founded by Erno Goldfinger. Oh, brilliant. The inspiration for Goldfinger, the Fort Knox robbing sort of rotund supervillain.
对她说：“我带你去巴黎过夏天吧。”于是她去了巴黎。她彻底爱上了——我的全盛时期的巴黎，真的。两次世界大战之间，画家蒙马特，所有那些东西，完全是这样。她实际上随后决定留下来，她待了一年，学习戏剧。我喜欢想象她做了很多哑剧表演。是的。在一个由埃尔诺·戈德芬格共同创立的剧院里。哦，太棒了。戈德芬格的灵感来源，那个抢劫诺克斯堡、胖乎乎的超级反派。
But he was an architect, wasn't he? He was an architect. Who Fleming fell out with. Yes, exactly. Because he was building, he was always building modernist buildings in Hampstead. I think that's the problem. Anyway, this isn't an issue at this stage.
但他是个建筑师，不是吗？他是个建筑师。弗莱明跟他闹翻了。是的，没错。因为他一直在建造，他总是在汉普斯特德建造现代主义建筑。我想问题就在这里。无论如何，这在现阶段不是问题。
She's in Paris. She's learning the theatre. She loves it so much, actually, that her father actually has to come to bring her back. So it's very kind of Dickie Greenleaf in Talents of Mr. Ripley.
她在巴黎。她在学习戏剧。她太喜欢了，以至于她的父亲不得不亲自去把她带回来。所以这有点像《天才瑞普利》里的迪基·格林利夫。
There's a kind of Patricia Highsmith quality slightly to the story. Definitely there is. And then a very Patricia Highsmith-ish kind of moment. She comes back to New York. So what is she now? She's about to the story. Definitely there is. And then a very Patricia Highsmith-ish kind of moment. She comes back to New York.
这个故事里有点帕特里夏·海史密斯式的特质。绝对有。然后是一个非常帕特里夏·海史密斯式的时刻。她回到了纽约。所以她现在多大了？她故事的主角。绝对有。然后是一个非常帕特里夏·海史密斯式的时刻。她回到了纽约。
So what is she now? She's about to turn 20 and she's crossing the road in New York and basically she steps into the traffic and is almost run over. Like Churchill.
所以她现在多大了？她快要20岁了，正在纽约过马路，基本上她一脚踏进车流中，差点被车撞了。就像丘吉尔一样。
Yeah, like Churchill. Exactly the same. I mean, uncanny. So all these kind of luminaries in the Second World War narrowly dodging being run over in New York. Yeah.
对，就像丘吉尔。完全一样。我的意思是，惊人的相似。所以二战中的这些名人都差一点在纽约被车撞。是的。
Very odd. I know. Yeah. Very odd. I know. It is very odd. Anyway, the bloke who pulled her back, Tom, would you believe it, is Condé Nast, the magazine. Oh, he's a person. Yeah. I had no idea.
很奇怪，我知道。对。很奇怪，我知道。这真的很奇怪。不管怎样，汤姆，拉住她的那个家伙，你敢信吗，是杂志大亨康泰纳仕。哦，他是一个人。对。我以前不知道。
Yeah. Condé Nast is a person. He's a sort of magazine and newspaper, more magazine than newspaper, tycoon. So it's Condé Nast that the world has to thank for Vogue and Vanity Fair. Condé Nast is a very kind of dapper man. He rescues her. And according to her son's biography, she, who has just got back from Paris, babbled in French in a glamorous manner at him.
对。康泰纳仕是一个人。他是一个杂志和报纸（杂志多于报纸）大亨。所以世界要感谢康泰纳仕才有了《Vogue》和《名利场》。康泰纳仕是一个非常文雅的人。他救了她。根据她儿子的传记，她这个刚从巴黎回来的人，以一种迷人的姿态在他面前用法语胡言乱语。
And he said, my dear. Is he French? No, he's American. He went to Georgetown University. So where does Condé come from? It's just showing off, isn't it? Yes. He says, my dear, you know, you're a very charming young woman.
他说：“我亲爱的……”他是法国人吗？不，他是美国人。他上过乔治敦大学。那康泰纳仕这个名字从哪来？这只是在炫耀，对吧？是的。他说：“我亲爱的，你知道，你是一个非常迷人的年轻女性。”
Would you care to model in my new magazine Vogue? And she does. By March 1927, so just a year after she's come back from paris she's on the front cover of vogue because she has a kind of very roaring 20s vibe doesn't she she definitely does so she's very tall she's very blonde she's a very striking very attractive woman you can see absolutely why she'd be such a hit and the most famous ad that she did actually which doesn't sound terribly glamorous she's's supposedly, I mean, I've actually done some digging into this and I can't really work out how true this is,
“你有兴趣为我的新杂志《Vogue》当模特吗？”她答应了。到1927年3月，也就是她从巴黎回来仅仅一年后，她就登上了《Vogue》的封面，因为她有一种非常浓厚的20世纪20年代的风情，不是吗？她绝对有。所以她很高，金发碧眼，是一个非常引人注目、极具吸引力的女性，你绝对能看出为什么她会如此受欢迎。她拍过的最著名的一个广告，听起来其实不怎么迷彩，据说——其实我对这件事做了一些深入挖掘，我不太确定这有多真实，
but it is said she is the first model to be photographed to advertise sanitary towels. This is a firm called Kotex. This ad ran in all the fashionable magazines and was sort of seen as groundbreaking and stuff. And at first she doesn't control her image the photos are taken for an agency and then they're kind of sold so at first she's a bit taken aback by it but actually she loved the kind of notoriety of it so in the bodleian yeah which i was doing intensive research yesterday yeah it said that this ruined her career yeah that's tosh and rubbish is it yeah? Yeah. Okay, well that's a mistake. Because she goes on to do loads of modelling.
但据说她是第一个为卫生巾广告担任拍摄的模特。这是一个叫Kotex的公司。这个广告刊登在所有时尚杂志上，当时被视为具有突破性等等。起初她并不掌控自己的形象，照片是为一家机构拍的，然后被卖掉了，所以起初她有点吃惊，但实际上她很喜欢由此带来的名气。所以在博德利图书馆，是的，我昨天在那里做了深入研究，是的，上面说这毁了她的事业。是的，那是胡说八道。是吗？是的。好吧，那是个错误。因为她接下来做了大量的模特工作。
Poor from the Bodleian. Yeah, they've let themselves down. Oh my God. Such a venerable library as well. Yeah. They've let me down, they've let Lee Miller down, but worst of all, they've let themselves down. Yeah, and they've let Kotex down, which is sad. Anyway, the thing is, she's not just interested in what's going on sort of in front of the
博德利图书馆真逊。是的，他们太让人失望了。天哪。这么德高望重的图书馆居然也这样。是的。他们让我失望了，让李·米勒失望了，但最糟糕的是，他们让自己失望了。是的，他们还让Kotex失望了，这挺令人难过的。不管怎样，关键是，她不仅对镜头前发生的事情感兴趣，
camera, but she's also interested in what's going behind it. Because her father is massively into his photography now. And at weekends, she'll spend the week in New York modelling. Then she'll go back to the Hudson Valley. They will experiment on photography together. Now, the one thing that I think is slightly odd is... Well, let's be honest. I mean, very odd.
她也对镜头后发生的事情感兴趣。因为她的父亲现在对摄影极其痴迷。到了周末——她一周都在纽约当模特，然后回到哈德逊河谷——他们会一起进行摄影实验。现在，有一件事我觉得有点奇怪……好吧，老实说。我的意思是，非常奇怪。
Yeah. His passion is nudes. Yeah. And he loves nudes of lee and she loves it but again this is all very kind of freudian psychology or you know alice in wonderland hint maybe more open-minded listeners than me may say what are they complaining about they're so repressed this is completely reasonable behavior i wouldn't have modeled for my father i was in my 20s some would you i don't want to go down this avenue no no well anyway i don't think you would frankly i don't want to presume but i don't think you would anyway she does that for a while but basically she can't wait to get back to paris so 1929 she goes to paris
对。他的激情是人体摄影。是的。他热爱李的人体摄影，她也很喜欢。但同样，这非常具有弗洛伊德心理学色彩，或者说有点像《爱丽丝梦游仙境》的暗示。也许思想比我更开放的听众会说：“他们在抱怨什么？你们太压抑了，这完全是合理的行为。”如果我二十多岁，我是不会给我父亲当模特的。你会吗？我不想顺着这个话题往下说。不，不。无论如何，坦白讲，我觉得你不会。我不想妄加揣测，但我觉得你不会。不管怎样，她干了一阵这个，但基本上她迫不及待地想回巴黎，所以在1929年她去了巴黎。
she's now very well connected obviously in kind of the modeling world, the fashion world, that kind of nexus. But also, Dominic, just to ask, so all of that, but also all this stuff about her dad taking photographs and things. And she's been having psychotherapy, presumably, you know, since a young age. I mean, this makes her absolutely ideal for all the surrealists who are in Paris. I mean, they're massively into all that, aren't they? Yeah, they are, of course. The sort of introspection, but also the obsession, obviously. Bunuel and Dali and all of that.
她现在在模特界、时尚界那种核心圈子里显然人脉极广。但是，多米尼克，顺便问一句，所有这些，还有她父亲拍照片之类的那些事。而且她一直在接受心理治疗，据推测，你知道的，从小时候起。我的意思是，这使她对巴黎的所有超现实主义者来说简直是绝配。我的意思是，他们对那一切极其痴迷，不是吗？是的，他们当然是。那种内省，还有迷恋，显而易见。布努埃尔、达利和所有那些人。
Yeah, the obsession, the sort of post-Freudian obsession with sex and all of that stuff. Absolutely. And as it happens, when she goes back to Paris, a friend gives her an introduction to a very well-known person, one of the best-known photographers in the world at this point, one of the best-known of all the surrealists, who is this guy, Man Ray. And Man Ray is actually from Philadelphia. He's American. He's Emmanuel Ratnitsky. I think he's a family of Russian, I think, immigrants.
对，这种迷恋，那种后弗洛伊德式的对性以及所有这些东西的迷恋。绝对是的。而且碰巧的是，当她回到巴黎时，一个朋友把她引荐给了一个非常知名的人物，这是当时世界上最著名的摄影师之一，也是所有超现实主义者中最知名的人物之一，这个人是谁呢，就是曼·雷。曼·雷其实来自费城。他是美国人。他叫伊曼纽尔·拉特尼茨基。我想他来自一个俄罗斯移民家庭。
And he was famous for his kind of Dadaist and then surrealist kind of collages and images and so on. Lee Miller said later that he kind of looked like a bull. He's this kind of very bear-like man, big eyebrows. And she just turns up to see him and says, I want to study with you. And he says, well, I don't have any students. Anyway, I'm going on holiday. I'm leaving Paris. And she said, brilliant. I'll come with you. And she did. And they ended up living together for three years. And they were a great partnership. He teaches about surrealism. He teaches photography and stuff. They have this kind of open relationship. Well, I read in your notes that she was known as Madame Man Ray. Yes.
他以达达主义风格随后转为超现实主义风格的拼贴画和影像等作品而闻名。李·米勒后来形容他长得像一头公牛。他是一个非常像熊的男人，浓眉大眼。她就直接去找他说：“我想跟你学摄影。”他说：“我没有学生。不管怎样，我要去度假了，我要离开巴黎。”她说：“太棒了，我和你一起去。”她真的去了。他们最后在一起生活了三年。他们是非常棒的合作伙伴。他教她超现实主义，教她摄影之类的。他们保持着那种开放式关系。好吧，我在你的笔记里读到她被称为“曼·雷夫人”。是的。
Whereas surely it would have been easier for her to be known simply as Woman Ray. I knew this joke was coming. This tremendous joke. It's a joke I've been waiting to make all the show. What's so shameful about this joke is that Theo crafted a joke for you overnight and you stamped on it very coldly. Well, I wasn't having my jokes upstage. So that you could use your own frankly weak joke. Oh, I think the listeners will be rolling in the aisles at that one. Okay.
而对她来说，直接被称为“雷女士”岂不是更简单？我早就知道这个笑话要来。这个了不起的笑话。这是我整场节目一直在等待的笑话。这个笑话最可耻的地方在于，特奥昨晚为你精心编排了一个笑话，而你却非常冷酷地把它踩在脚下。好吧，我可不想让我的笑话被人抢了风头。这样你就可以用你那个坦白讲很烂的笑话了。哦，我觉得听众们听到那个笑话一定会笑得前仰后合的。好吧。
So she's still doing a lot of modelling. She's modelling for the Parisian edition of Vogue. Cecil Beaton, British photographer who actually... Cecil Beaton, my erstwhile neighbour. Yeah, of course. Yeah. We used to kick footballs over his wall and go and roam in his garden. Yeah.
所以她仍然在做大量的模特工作。她为法国版的《Vogue》当模特。塞西尔·比顿，英国摄影师，实际上……塞西尔·比顿，我以前的邻居。对，没错。是的。我们以前经常把足球踢过他的墙，去他的花园里溜达。是的。
It's nice to think that I have a link to 1920s Paris. So Cecil Beaton said of Lee Miller, he didn't even like Lee Miller, but he said, she looked like a sun-kissed goat boy from the Appian Way. Didn't he say that of you? He may well have done, actually, thinking back. He's a very entertaining figure in the film, just mentioning that. Okay. I felt upset on Cecil Beaton's behalf.
想到我和20世纪20年代的巴黎有这样的联系，感觉真好。所以塞西尔·比顿对李·米勒的评价是——他甚至不喜欢李·米勒，但他说：“她看起来像个来自阿比亚大道、被太阳晒黑的牧山羊的小男孩。”他没对你这么说过吗？回想起来，他很有可能这么说过。他在电影里是一个非常有趣的人物，顺便提一下。好吧。我为塞西尔·比顿感到难过。
Really? A bit. Right. I've always had a soft spot for him. He was always very nice to us. You know, he didn't mind us running around like whatever it was like goat boys on the Appian Way goat boys on the Appian Way he was very into that
真的吗？有一点。好吧。我一直对她很有好感。他一直对我们很好。你知道的，他不介意我们到处乱跑，不管那像什么——就像阿比亚大道上的牧山羊小男孩，阿比亚大道上的牧山羊小男孩，他非常喜欢那个。
okay so she's massively into her surrealism loves all that she gets her own apartment she gets her own studio by 1930 just down the road from Man Ray's studio and she starts to carve out a little bit of a niche for herself as somebody who's not just modelling but also taking photos.
好吧，所以她极度迷恋超现实主义，非常喜欢那些。她在1930年就有了自己的公寓，自己的工作室，就在曼·雷工作室的马路对面，她开始为自己开辟出一小片天地，不仅仅是当模特，还开始拍照。
So not just a muse, in other words. Not just a muse, exactly. History's full of muses of this kind, but she is more ambitious than that. And especially in Paris at that time. Yeah, of course. I mean, that's what Picasso's all about. She's more ambitious because she is taking kind of society portraits. So she's doing loads of kind of bohemian people.
换句话说，不只是一个缪斯。不只是一个缪斯，完全如此。历史上有无数这种类型的缪斯，但她比那些更有野心。尤其是在当时的巴黎。是的，当然。我的意思是，毕加索就是那样的。她更有野心，因为她在拍摄某种社会肖像。所以她在拍一大堆波西米亚风格的人。
She gets in with the French aristocracies. This is the thing about the nexus between the fashion industry and the sort of early 20th century fashion industry and the world
她打入了法国贵族圈子。这就是时尚产业与20世纪初时尚产业以及
of high society kind of aristocratic types. She has all these kind of aristocratic friends, doesn't she? Can I tell you about one of them? Do. Who I read about
上流社会那种贵族类型世界之间的联系所在。她有所有这些贵族朋友，不是吗？我能跟你讲讲其中一个吗？讲吧。我昨天在博德利图书馆读到的。
in the Bodleian yesterday. Yeah. It's an interesting link to the French Revolution. I love a link to the French Revolution. And also a link to the French Revolution. And also she's in the film, she's played by Marianne Cotillard.
这是一个与法国大革命有趣的联系。我喜欢与法国大革命的联系。而且也是与法国大革命的联系。而且她在电影里由玛丽昂·歌迪亚扮演。
And this is Solange Marie Christine Louise de Labrif, the Duchess of Aisne, who is married, Dominic, to the son of the 8th Duke of Nye. Nye. Nye. So remind me, the Duchess of Nye was the person
这就是索朗日·玛丽·克里斯蒂娜·路易丝·德拉布里夫，艾恩公爵夫人，多米尼克，她嫁给了第八代内公爵的儿子。内。内。提醒我一下，内公爵夫人就是那个
who greeted Marie Antoinette when she arrived in yeah and Sticla for etiquette and Lafayette married into the family right
当玛丽·安托瓦内特抵达时迎接她的人，并且精通礼仪，拉斐特也跟这个家族联姻了，对吧？
and her son is the guy who kicks off the abrogation of feudal privileges yeah that's right in the National Assembly should have done it
她的儿子正是那个在国民议会中发起废除封建特权的人。没错，他本该早两年这么做的。
two years earlier so she's the fashion editor of French Vogue she lives in a chateau she's the kind of the beating heart of Le Tout Paris and you know it's that's great I She's the kind of the beating heart of Le Tout Paris.
所以她是法国版《Vogue》的时尚编辑，她住在城堡里，她是“巴黎上流社会”（Le Tout Paris）的核心，你知道的……那太棒了。她是“巴黎上流社会”的核心，你知道的……那太棒了。我的意思是，这有点像普鲁斯特式的，我猜。是的，这很普鲁斯特。普鲁斯特、毕加索、科克托、可可·香奈儿。她是朋友。我的意思是，这太神奇了。就像伍迪·艾伦那部以巴黎为背景的电影，他们在那里跑来跑去见海明威和其他所有人。没错。
And, you know, it's... That's great. I mean, it's kind of Proustian, I guess. Yeah, it is Proustian. Proust, Picasso, Cocteau, Coco Chanel. She's friends. I mean, it's amazing. It's like that Woody Allen film set in Paris where they kind of rush around meeting Hemingway and everybody. Right.
基本上，巴黎所有的名人都被她见了个遍。你知道吗？她父亲在1930年12月过来看她，他是一个来自……他给她拍照吗？波基普西。哦，亲爱的。你想把衣服脱了吗，李？为了老交情，你想脱衣服吗，我们拍张快照？
Basically, every famous person in Paris, she is meeting. And do you know what? Her father comes over in December 1930 and he's a man from- Does he take photographs of her? Poughkeepsie. Oh, my darling. Do you want to take your clothes off, Lee? Do you want to, for old time's sake, and we'll take a quick photo?
他从纽约波基普西赶来，他是个工场主管，还记得吗？你会想，如果这是一部电影，你知道，如果这一段是电影，你就会说他此刻一定会非常震惊。你知道的，他会非常失望。不，他喜欢……如果这一段是电影，你就会说他此刻一定会非常震惊。他会非常失望。不，他喜欢。你知道他特别喜欢谁吗？曼·雷。他喜欢曼·雷。
He comes over from Poughkeepsie, New York, and he's a work superintendent, remember? And you would think, now if this was a film, you know, if this bit was a film, you would say he'll be very shocked at this point. You know, he'll be very disappointed. No, he loves a film, you would say he'll be very shocked at this point. He'll be very disappointed. No, he loves it. And you know who he particularly likes? Man Ray. He loves Man Ray.
简直爱不释手。他们俩都是摄影师，对吧？曼·雷说：“哦，我发明了一个绝妙的新三脚架。”西奥多·米勒对此——这不是双关语——西奥多·米勒对此感到极其高兴。简直爱不释手。所以这都很好。但有一朵乌云。实际上有无数朵乌云。但这是其中一朵。双关语，西奥多·米勒对此感到极其高兴，简直爱不释手。所以这都很好。但有一朵乌云。实际上有无数朵乌云。但这是其中一朵。这是一朵埃及的云。所以她最后在巴黎和这个叫阿齐兹·埃卢伊·贝的家伙谈恋爱，
Can't get enough of him. They're both photographers, aren't they? Man Ray says, oh, I've invented a brilliant new tripod. And Theodore Miller is absolutely, it's not a euphemism, and Theodore Miller is absolutely delighted by this. Can't get enough of it. So that's all great. But there is a cloud. There are numerous clouds, actually. But this is one. euphemism and Theodore Miller is absolutely delighted by this can't get enough of it so that's all great but there is a cloud there are numerous clouds actually but this is one it's an Egyptian cloud so she ends up having a relationship in Paris with this guy called
他娶了一个切尔克斯女人，切尔克斯女人以美貌闻名，不是吗？她们非常美丽，过去曾在港口提供女奴，是的，没错。和切尔克斯人离婚是疯狂的行为，而这正是这家伙所做的。他和他妻子离婚了，因为他太迷恋李了。但同时，在这个时候，曼·雷已经完全陷进去了。他占有欲极强。阿齐兹先生，我的意思是，他非常有钱吗？我想他是很有钱的，是的。
Aziz Eloui Bey who's married a Circassian woman who are famously beautiful aren't they the Circassians they're very beautiful it was providing the slave girls in the harbors yeah exactly madness to divorce as a Circassian which is what this bloke does. He divorces his wife because he's so infatuated with Lee. But also by this point, Man Ray, he's all in. He's very possessive. And is Mr. Aziz, I mean, is he very rich? I think he is rich, yeah.
他非常迷人吗？他非常温文尔雅吗？他是什么样的人？他是奥马尔·谢里夫。多迪·法耶德。嗯，是的，这是一个稍微没那么……我觉得奥马尔·谢里夫是一个更有吸引力的对象，而不是多迪·法耶德，对吧？是的。我的意思是，我不是在贬低多迪·法耶德，但多迪·法耶德出资制作了《杀戮战场》、
Is he very charming? Is he very suave? What is he? He's Omar Sharif. Dodi Al-Fayed. Well, yes, that's a slightly less, I think Omar Sharif is more, is a more enticing proposition than Dodi Al-Fayed, isn't he? Yeah. I mean, not dissing Dodi Al-Fayed, but Dodi Al-Fayed put up the finance for the Killingfields,
《火的战车》。是的，《火的战车》。制片人说他是他这辈子见过最懒的人。他总是待在游艇上，对吧？是的。经常在巴黎的餐馆里闲逛。是的。所以无论如何，她逃离了这场爱情的拔河战。
Chariots of Fire. Yeah, Chariots of Fire. And the producer said he was the laziest man he'd ever met in his life. He's always on yachts, isn't he? Yeah. Kind of hanging out in restaurants in Paris. Yeah. So anyway, she flees away from this love tug of war, tug of love.
她逃回了纽约。她开了自己的工作室。所以当时的纽约正处于大萧条的低谷。那是1932年底。街上到处都是施粥棚，你知道的，有挨饿的人。她对这些一点兴趣都没有。当然，她后来会对生活的残酷现实以及在照片中捕捉这些非常感兴趣，但1932年时她可不感兴趣。所以她把晚上的时间花在打扑克、
She flees back to New York. She opens her own studio. So New York is now in the depths of the Depression. It's late 1932. There would have been soup kitchens, you know, starving people on the streets. She's not interested in that at all. She will, of course, be very interested in the gritty reality of life and capturing that in her photographs but not in 1932 so she's spending her kind of nights playing poker and
跳舞和那种上流社会的高质量生活上，白天则拍一些社交名流的照片——这又是一种那种多萝西·帕克式的俏皮阔太，你知道的，地下酒吧，绝对的。她真的在体验战间期的每一个现成的陈词滥调，完全如此，然后活出了精彩。接着在1934年夏天，也就是两年后，这个叫阿齐兹的家伙出现在纽约，他们重燃了爱火。她把他介绍给她的父亲。我不知道他们是否因摄影而建立感情。我觉得没有。是的。
dancing and that kind of high life and a day society photos which again it's that kind of dorothy parker yeah wisecracking broads you know yeah speakeasies absolutely she really is kind of inhabiting every going cliche in the interwar years exactly and she's living it to the full she is absolutely then in the summer of 1934 to two years later this bloke aziz turns up in new york and they sort of rekindled their romance. She introduces him to her father. I don't know whether they bond over photography. I don't think they do. Yeah.
那么阿齐兹对摄影感兴趣吗？我觉得他不是特别感兴趣，其实。我觉得他对李·米勒感兴趣。他对李·米勒感兴趣。还有，这里有个有趣的事。他对空调非常感兴趣。是吗？是的。
So is Aziz into photography? I don't think he is massively, actually. I think he's into Lee Miller. He's into Lee Miller. But also, here's an interesting thing. He's really into air conditioning. Is he? Yeah.
此时的开罗不可能有多少空调吧。没有，他是早期介入者，早期采用者。他有一份来自埃及政府的合同，要提供大量的空调，这将成为他晚年生活的一个主题。不管怎样，有趣的是，她把他介绍给父母，并说阿迪先生……她喜欢他的空调，太棒了。她的父母觉得：“哦，一个迷人的……”然后令他们震惊的是，因为他们见过她无数的男朋友，她和他一起去了埃及领事馆，在纽约结了婚。所有人都对此大跌眼镜。
There can't be much air conditioning in Cairo at this pointro at this point no he's in on it early early adopter he has a contract from the egyptian government to provide a lot of air conditioning and this will become a theme of his later life um anyway interesting she introduces him to her parents and she says that mr adi she loves his air conditioning brilliant and uh her parents think oh a charming. And then to their astonishment, because they've met loads of her boyfriends, she goes off with him to the Egyptian consulate and gets married to him in New York. And everyone is astounded by that.
我的意思是，这是真爱吗？我觉得她是……我觉得这只是一场恶作剧。好吧。有点像恶作剧。令人失望的是，或许有点老套，你知道他们去哪里度蜜月吗？我知道，因为你写在笔记上了。是的。装作你不知道。我不知道，多米尼克。
I mean, is it love? I think she's... I think it's a lark. Okay. A bit of a lark. Disappointingly, perhaps slightly prosaically, do you know where they go on their honeymoon? I do, because you've got it down on the notes. Yeah. Pretend you don't know. I don't dominate. Where where they go on their honeymoon? I do, because you've got it down on the notes. Yeah. Pretend you don't know. I don't, Dominic.
他们去哪里度蜜月？他们去了尼亚加拉大瀑布。对我来说，这作为蜜月来说有点像旅游大巴团的行程了，即使在20世纪30年代也是如此。是的，但也许这在超现实主义风格中带有某种讽刺意味。是的，就像在拉斯维加斯结婚之类的。你觉得有点讽刺吗？是的，我不知道。不管怎样，他们随后去了埃及。所以她在接下来的三年里一直待在开罗。
Where do they go on honeymoon? They go to Niagara Falls. To me, that's a bit coach party for a honeymoon, even in the 1930s. Yeah, but maybe it's ironic in a surrealist way. Yeah, like getting married in Las Vegas or something. It's slightly ironic, do you think? Yeah, I don't know. Anyway, they then go off to Egypt. So she's then in Cairo for the next three years.
开罗，开罗，是的。她其实……这并不像你想象的那么光鲜亮丽、充满异国情调。然而，多米尼克，然而，她确实拍了一张照片，后来被伟大的比利时超现实主义画家勒内·马格利特在1938年采用。她确实拍了。我知道她拍了。她在沙漠里拍的，对吧？
Cairo. Cairo, yeah. She doesn't actually, it's not as glamorous and exotic as you would think. However, Dominic, however, she does take a photograph that will subsequently be employed by the great Belgian surrealist painter René Magritte in 1938. She does. I know she does. She does that in the desert, doesn't she?
是的。但我们有一封她1935年写给父母的信。她已经有一年左右没和他们联系了。她说：“我度过了极其快乐和健康的一年，我的时间花在每周六早晨在美利坚大学学习化学，以及每周三个下午学习阿拉伯语。还有大量的扑克和桥牌。”我觉得这是一种非常棒的打发时间的方式。
Yeah. But we have a letter to her parents in 1935. She hasn't communicated to them for about a year. She says, I've spent an extremely happy and healthy year, my time being occupied between studying chemistry six mornings a week at the American University and three afternoon hours a week of Arabic. Also a great deal of poker and bridge. I think that's quite an impressive way to pass your time.
学了一年化学？得了吧，多米尼克，你才不会去学化学呢。我不会。我不会。所以你没有任何资格指责别人。好吧。她确实做了更刺激的事。她仍然在坚持摄影。
A year of doing chemistry? Come on, Dominic, you're not going to be doing chemistry. I wouldn bridge. I think that's quite an impressive way to pass your time. A year of doing chemistry? Come on, Dominic, you're not going to be doing chemistry. I wouldn't. I wouldn't. So I don't think you're in any position to throw stones. Okay. Well, she does do this more exciting. She's still keeping up with her photography.
所以她去了耶路撒冷一天。她去了西奈山的修道院。你去过吗？去过，我去过。你对那里一定轻车熟路。是的，我实际上在那里拍过片。去过吗？所以你比她更胜一筹。
So she goes to Jerusalem for a day. She goes to the monasteries in Sinai. Have you been to them? Yes, I have. You must be all over them. Yeah, I've filmed there, actually. Have you? So you've gone one better.
她当时只是在拍静态照片。是的，我在那里更胜一筹并拉了坨大的。她去了一个我知道你没去过的地方，锡瓦绿洲，亚历山大大帝曾在那里面对神谕被奉为宙斯·阿蒙之子。她拍了所有这些关于沙漠的精彩照片。
She was just taking still photographs. Yeah, I've one-upped and shit there. She goes somewhere I know you haven't been, the oasis of Siwa, where Alexander was proclaimed the son of Zeus Amon. And she takes all these fantastic photos of the desert.
所以如果你看一本关于李·米勒沙漠摄影的书，它们非常具有超现实主义色彩，而且非常严峻、非常引人注目。它们显然极具时代特色，所以它有点像——嗯，它们就像马格利特的画。是的，它们非常超现实，非常严峻和引人注目，显然极具时代特色，所以它有点像——它们就像马格利特的画。是的，那是那种被风吹拂的岩石，呈现出某种阴茎的形状，所有这一类的东西，
So if you look at one of the books on Lima and Lanuga, her desert photographs, they're quite surrealist and they're very stark and very striking. They're obviously very much of their time. So it's kind of- Well, they're like a Magrita painting. Yeah, they're quite surrealist and they're very stark and very striking they're obviously very much of their time so it's kind of they're like a magrita painting yeah they're kind of windswept rocks in a sort of phallic formation and all this kind of thing
云层在沙丘上方隐现，所有这些看起来就像女性裸露躯干的东西，完全如此，完全如此，那就是它的本意。或者像鸽子的翅膀。但她显然，坦率地说，对阿齐兹先生有点厌倦了。空调只有那么多。聊天。
um clouds looming over the over the dunes all this sort of business that look like the naked female torso exactly exactly that's exactly what it is. Or the wings of a dove. But she's clearly, frankly, a bit bored with Mr. Mr. He's only so much air conditioning. Chat.
人们可以忍受空调的闲聊。人们可以忍受，说到闲聊。所以她有时会回巴黎。当她在巴黎时，她遇到了这个把头发染了一部分的富有英国人——这就是电影里的亚历山大·斯卡斯加德。
One can air conditioning banter. One can put up with, but talking of banter. So she sometimes goes back to Paris. And when she's in Paris, she meets this posh Englishman who has partly dyed himself. So this is Alexander Skarsgård. In the film.
电影里。现实中的罗兰·彭罗斯，他为了超现实主义的恶作剧原因，把头发染成了一部分亮蓝色。但不是永久的。不，不是永久的。所以他是罗兰·彭罗斯。他是一个贵格会教徒。贵格会教徒是《历史其余部分》的一个常见主题。他是个贵格会教徒。
In the film. Roland Penrose in reality, who has partly dyed himself bright blue for surrealist bants reasons. But not permanently. No, not permanently. So he's Roland Penrose. He is a Quaker. Quakers are such a theme of the rest of his history. He's a Quaker. Yeah, we love a Quaker. Quakers are such a theme of the rest of his history. He's a Quaker.
是的，我们喜欢贵格会教徒。理查德·尼克松，本杰明·莱伊。而且，他去了我母校剑桥大学的皇后学院。真的吗？是的。天哪，全都连上了。是的。塞西尔·比顿。
Yeah, we love a Quaker. Richard Nixon, Benjamin Lay. And also, he went to Queen's College, Cambridge, my alma mater. Really? Yeah. God, it all connects. Yeah. Cecil Beaton.
你在西奈山拍过片。你把球踢过去过。我在模仿李·米勒的生活。这真是一个可怕的画面。所以他是一个贵格会教徒。他是一个兵役反对者。他是毕加索和各种超现实主义者的超级好友。因为他有着惊人的收藏，不是吗？
You filmed at Sinai. You kicked a ball over. I am shadowing Lee Miller's life. That's a terrifying image. So he's a Quaker. He's a conscientious objector. He's a tremendous friend of Picasso and of various surrealists. Because he's got an amazing collection, hasn't he?
难以置信。是的，他后来成了……他创立了ICA（当代艺术协会），对吧？是的。他创立了当代艺术研究所。他成为了英国当代艺术界德高望重的老前辈。剧透一下，他的战争经历非常传奇。确实如此。
Incredible. Yeah, and he goes on to become... He founds the ICA, doesn't he, or something? He does. He founds the Institute for Contemporary Art. He becomes the grand old man of British contemporary art. And just a spoiler, he has a tremendous war. He does, indeed.
所以他是一个有趣的混合体，一方面他是贵格会教徒，所以他非常正式，非常有教养；另一方面他是超现实主义者，所以他喜欢把头发染成蓝色——所以他是蓝色的，像古代不列颠人一样蓝，我猜。无论如何，他们开始了这段恋情，他们去巴尔干半岛等地旅行，他实际上来到埃及看望她，我想她和阿齐兹保持着类似于曼·雷风格的开放式关系，因为他们都是极好的朋友。1939年春天，她对阿齐兹说——当时正在讨论空调机的事——她说：“我有件事要告诉你，我决定去和这个蓝色家伙混在一起了。”是的，和这个蓝色贵格会教徒去英国。好吧，阿齐兹说：“我亲爱的，我亲爱的……”
So he's a funny mix because on the one hand he's a quaker so he's very formal and he's very kind of well-mannered on the other hand he's a surrealist so he loves dying himself blue so he's blue he's blue like an ancient britain i guess anyway they start this relationship and they go traveling the balkans and stuff and he actually comes out to egypt to see her and i think she must have with aziz the similar kind of man ray style open relationship because they're all tremendous friends and um in the spring of 1939 she says to aziz is talking about air conditioning units and she says i've got something to tell you i've decided to go and uh hang out with this blue guy yeah go to england with this blue quaker fair enough as. And Aziz says, you know, my dear, my dear,
所以他是一个很有趣的组合，一方面他是贵格会教徒，所以他非常正式、很有礼貌；另一方面他又是个超现实主义者，所以他喜欢把自己染成蓝色，他全身都是蓝的，就像古代的布立吞人一样。总之，他们开始交往，一起去巴尔干半岛等地旅行，他甚至还来到埃及看望她。我想她和阿齐兹之间一定也保持着类似曼·雷风格的开放式关系，因为他们都是极好的朋友。嗯，在1939年春天，她对阿齐兹说——当时他们正在谈论空调设备——她对他说：我有件事要告诉你，我决定去和这个蓝色的家伙在一起了，没错，要和这个蓝色的贵格会教徒一起去英国。好吧，就这样。阿齐兹则说，你知道的，我亲爱的，我亲爱的，
I'm very pleased for you. I'll give you some money. And he even comes to Port Said to see her off on their boat to Southampton. So by the late summer of 1939, she has moved in with Roland in Hampstead, naturally. Does Mr. Aziz provide air conditioning? Do you need it in North London?
我为你感到高兴。我会给你一些钱。甚至连他都亲自来到塞得港，为她送行，目送他们坐船去南安普敦。所以到1939年夏末，她很自然地搬去汉普斯特德和罗兰同居了。阿齐兹先生提供空调吗？北伦敦需要空调吗？
I don't believe you do. Probably not. And also there'd be no room for it. But Mr. Goldfinger. Yeah. He'd be all into it. They must be neighbors of Goldfinger. Yeah, I don't connect.
我觉得你不需要。大概不需要。而且也没地方装。不过戈德芬格先生。对。他肯定会对这个很感兴趣。他们俩一定和戈德芬格是邻居。好吧，我没把这联系起来。
Anyway, there wouldn't be any room because his house is full of artworks. Picasso, Braque, Miro, Magritte, all of this stuff. And when she arrives in the house, she actually says, my God, you've got so many brilliant copies. They look like the originals. And he sort of says, my dear, they are the originals. But then, Tom, so I was reading all this in the biography and I was like, this is great. Love all this.
总之，那里根本没有地方，因为他的房子里全都是艺术品。毕加索、布拉克、米罗、马格里特，全都是这些东西。当她来到这座房子时，她实际上说：“天哪，你竟然有这么多精妙的复制品。它们看起来就像真迹一样。”而他大概就说：“亲爱的，这些就是真迹。”但是呢，汤姆，我当时在传记里读到所有这些内容时，我就想：这太棒了。我太喜欢这些了。
And then I turned the page and do you know what the sentence that I read next, Tom? The clouds of war were gathering. And they were. Of course they were. And the greatest adventure of lee miller's life was about to begin okay well let's take a break there and when we come back we will be looking at the extraordinary story of lee miller's record in the second world war and indeed rowland's
然后我翻过了一页，你知道我接下来读到的是哪句话吗，汤姆？“战争的阴云正在密布。”它们确实在密布。当然是的。莉·米勒一生命中最伟大的冒险即将开始了。好吧，那我们在那儿休息一下，等我们回来后，我们将关注莉·米勒在第二次世界大战中的传奇经历，以及罗兰的经历。
this episode is sponsored by our good friends at sky all because their new sky original film lee is available from friday the 13th of september only in cinemas now tom i know you love a red carpet premiere you've been to a few red carpet premieres thanks to the rest is history but you had a personal screening is that possible are you important? Well, as I mentioned in this episode, it was in Gary Lineker's private cinema at Goldhanger Towers, and it was a pretty luxurious experience. Well, I'll leave it to listeners to make up their own minds what they think of that. But Tom, what do you think of the film? It's really gripping. It kind of wonderfully conveys the sense of Lee Miller's life before
本集节目由我们的好朋友天空电视台（Sky）赞助播出，因为他们全新出品的天空原创电影《李》将于9月13日星期五上映，仅限各大影院。汤姆，我知道你很喜欢走红毯首映礼，在“历史就是这样”节目组的安排下，你也去过不少红毯首映礼。不过你居然拥有私人观影专场，这可能吗？你很有面子吗？嗯，正如我在本期节目中提到的，那是在加1尼线克（Gary Lineker）位于戈德亨格尔塔（Goldhanger Towers）的私人影院里，那是一次相当奢华的体验。好吧，我就让听众们自己去想象他们对此作何感想了。不过汤姆，你觉得这部电影怎么样？真的非常引人入胜。它在某种程度上完美地传达了莉·米勒战前的生活气息。
the war. And so what we talk about in this episode, the way in which she goes from being the cutting edge of the avant-garde, high society, all of that, to becoming this hard-boiled, almost kind of female GI, who goes absolutely into the heart of the Nazi darkness. It's really good. Yeah. And of course, it's photography like hers, kind of Second World War photography that lays the foundation for a lot of the kind of war correspondence
所以在本期节目中我们讨论的是，她如何从前卫艺术的最前沿、上流社会等等，转变成这样一个饱经风霜、几乎可以说是女美国大兵的形象，她深入到了纳粹黑暗的核心。这真的很棒。是的。当然，正是像她这样的摄影，也就是第二次世界大战的那种摄影，为我们后来联系到许多冲突的战地记者工作和战地摄影奠定了基础。
and war photography stuff that we associate with later conflicts. So Vietnam, for example. Yeah. So on the Vietnam War, there's an amazing sequence where she sees the first use of napalm in Sao Malo. And it's one of the kind of the great moments in the film.
比如越南战争。是的。所以在越南战争期间，有一个非常惊艳的镜头，她看到了在圣马洛首次使用凝固汽油弹。这也是电影中的高光时刻之一。
So highly, highly recommended. Lee is out in cinemas from Friday, the 13th of September, and you can go to sky.com to find out more. The building we were in and all the others which face the fort were being spat at now. Ping, bang, hitting above our window, into the next, breaking on the balcony below. Fast, queer noise. Impact before the gun noise itself, following the same sound pattern, hundreds of rounds, crossing and recrossing where we were. Machine gun fire belched from the end pillbox. The men fell flat, stumbling and crawling into the shelter of shell holes. Some crept on, others sweeping back to the
所以强烈强烈推荐。电影《李》将于9月13日星期五在各大影院上映，你可以访问sky.com了解更多信息。我们当时所在的建筑以及所有其他正对堡垒的建筑现在都在遭到攻击。砰，啪，击中我们头顶上方的窗户，打进旁边的窗户，在下方的阳台上碎裂。快而怪异的声音。在枪声本身响起之前就产生的冲击力，遵循着同样的声响模式，成百上千发子弹，在我们所在的地方来回穿梭。机枪的火力从那个碉堡的尽头喷涌而出。士兵们趴倒在地，跌跌撞撞地爬进弹坑的掩护中。有些人继续匍匐前进，另一些人则退回到枪口斜角以左的方向，有一个人爬到了顶部。他体型高大，是一个肩膀宽阔的剪影，在碉堡和堡垒之间的天空中显得黑乎乎的。他举起手臂，那是骑兵军官挥舞着军刀催促其他人前进的手势。他是在向死神挥手，最终他倒了下去，手搭在堡垒上。这就是莉·米勒1944年10月在《时尚》杂志上发表的文章。她当时正在描述圣马洛战役，而她就身处其中。在凯特·温丝莱特的电影中，这就是这部电影开场的情节，是非常戏剧化的那种《兄弟连》风格的动作戏，多米尼克，这与前半部分的所有那些摄影、空调、精神分析、蓝色毕加索和蓝色桂格麦片等等形成了巨大的反差，不是吗？所以这到底是怎么回事？她是怎么从所有这一切变成在1944年被解放的法国遭到枪击的呢？
left of the gun's angle, one man reaching the top. He was enormous, a square-shouldered silhouette, black against the sky between the pillbox and the fort. He raised his arm, the gesture of a cavalry officer with saber waving the others on. He was waving to death, and he fell with his hand against the fort. So that was Lee Miller writing in Vogue in October 1944. And she's describing the battle for San Marlo, which she is in the middle of it. And in the Kate Winslet film, this is what the film opens with, very dramatic kind of band of brothers style action sequence and dominic it's a huge contrast isn't it with all the uh the photography and the air conditioning and the psychoanalysis and blueness casso and blue quakers and stuff of the first half so what's going on how does she get
这就是一个非凡的故事。我想你可以说，在某种程度上，这就是20世纪30年代和40年代西方社会在一个人生命中的缩影。所以正如你所说，从那个聚会、摄影和超现实主义恶作剧的世界，非常突然地过渡到1944年圣马洛那场极其残酷的战役，这真的非常引人注目，老兄，我是这么想的。我的意思是，她并不是真的以作家身份闻名，但她受到了……我猜，她后来不是还做了一组关于乔伊斯的都柏林的战后摄影系列吗，其中有一种现代主义散文的影响，对吧？
from all that to being shot at um in liberated France in 1944. Well, it's a remarkable story. And I suppose you could say in a way that's the story of Western society in the 1930s and 1940s in microcosm in one person's life. So the very abrupt transition from, as you say, that world of parties and photography and surrealist larks to the sort of deadly serious battle for sam arlo in 1944 it's quite striking bros i think i mean she's not really renowned as a writer but but she's influenced by i guess well she goes on doesn't she to do a kind of photo sequence after the war about joyce's dublin and there's a kind of the influence of modernist prose there yeah
海明威之类的人，这正是你会期待的，或者海明威，对吧。而且我认为另一个引人注目的是，那篇报道是发表在《时尚》杂志上的，那是英国《时尚》还是美国《时尚》？是的，英国《时尚》。好的，那是和奥黛丽·威瑟斯（Audrey Withers）合作的，她是她的编辑，是的。所以我们在1939年留下的印象是，她抵达了英国，而在几周之内，战争的风暴云就爆发了，并且……已经彻底破裂了，对吧。所以英国参战了，她立刻自愿为英国《时尚》杂志效劳，实际上他们让她做的是——我的意思是，这体现了那种“假战”的状态——起初在1939年、1940年，他们真的只是让她去拍摄手提包的照片。杂志上会有一个关于当季精美新腰带的专题报道。
Hemingway or something which is exactly what you'd expect or Hemingway yeah exactly and I think the other the striking thing it's in vogue that that report is that British vogue or American vogue yes British vogue okay so that's with Audrey Withers who's her editor yes so we so we left there in 1939 having arrived in uh britain and within weeks the the storm clouds of war have burst and um have broken they're broken yeah so britain's at war and she immediately volunteers her services to british vogue and actually what they use her to do is i mean this is a sign of the kind of phony war that at first, 1939, 1940, they're literally using her to take photographs of handbags. There'll be a sort of feature on nice new belts in the season.
她这么做是因为，当然，对大多数人来说，在英国的战争，战争还没有波及到他们。战争发生在波兰。那是别的地方。不过她确实遇到了对她刻薄的塞西尔·比顿（Cecil Beaton）。是的，没错。他一直对她非常刻薄。相当折磨人。但直到1940年夏秋之交左右。所以在敦刻尔克之后，在不列颠之战后，在伦敦大轰炸期间，
And she's doing it because, of course, for most people, the war in Britain, the war has not yet impinged. The war is happening in Poland. It's somewhere else. But she does have Cecil Beaton being catty to her. Yes, that's right. He is consistently very catty. Pretty gruelling. But as late as sort of the summer, autumn of 1940. So after Dunkirk, after the Battle of Britain, during the Blitz,
你翻开《时尚》杂志，里面根本提都没有提战争。极少提到战争。所以《时尚》杂志实际上在1940年10月遭到轰炸，但杂志的印刷并没有停止。大概是因为人们的设想是，人们需要它来作为对和平世界、舒适世界的提醒，在那里你不用被配给，在那里你购买的衣服没有限制。没错。至少一开始是这样的，我想。而且我认为这反映了一个更广泛的问题，那就是在英国，特别是1939年和1940年的前半段，战争实际上是隔着一层发生的，人们不希望它感觉是真实的，你知道的，他们不希望英国变得像波兰或者别的什么地方、挪威那样，他们想要像你说的，保留一点……
you can open Vogue and there is no mention of the war at all. Very little mention of the war. So Vogue was actually bombed in October 1940 and production of the magazine didn't stop. Presumably because the assumption is that people want it as a reminder of the world of peace, the world of comfort, where you're not being rationed, where there aren't restrictions on the clothing you can buy. That's right. Certainly at first, I think. And I think that speaks to a wider issue, which is that in Britain in in particular in 1939 and the first part of 1940 the war is really happening at one remove and people don't want it to feel real you know they don't want britain to be like poland or wherever norway they want to preserve as you say a bit of
生活，哪怕只是一点正常的生活。但实际上，《时尚》杂志因为印刷和纸张配给已经改为纯订阅制了。所以实际上她做的所有这些东西，内容很好，汤姆，但它并没有摆上报摊。它完全是专供《时尚》杂志订阅者的。这非常类似于“历史就是这样”俱乐部的会员专享。非常类似于我们为“历史就是这样”俱乐部制作的加更节目。
life but actually yeah a bit of normal life But Vogue has gone to subscription only because of print and paper rationing. So actually all this stuff that she's doing, it's good stuff, Tom, but it's not reaching the newsstands. It's exclusively for Vogue subscribers. So very much like the Rest Is History Club. Very much like the bonus episodes that we do for the Rest Is History Club.
没错。而这些实际上才是最好的，不是吗？这就是我脑海中浮现的比喻。是的。这完全就是我想到的比喻。确实是最好的，不是吗？那就是击中我的比喻。是的。这完全是自然而然浮现在脑海中的比喻。总之，她非常热衷于此。你知道，她有这种好奇心和雄心。
Exactly. Which are actually the best, aren't they? That was the analogy that struck me. Yeah. That was completely the analogy that's going for the Restless History Club, exactly. Which are actually the best, aren't they? That was the analogy that struck me. Yeah. That was completely the analogy that's going to mind, organically. Anyway, she's very keen. You know, she has this curiosity and this ambition.
所以她很渴望走出去，真正地记录战争。所以就像我们开场时提到的那个埃德·默里（Ed Murray）的事情一样。是的。她当时觉得自己是在为英国的战争大局尽自己的一份力吗？我想是的。我绝对这么认为。因为她的一些照片非常适合用来做宣传，特别是为了鼓舞美国人的士气。如果你看过你一开始提到的《严酷的荣耀》（Grim Glory）那本书，里面最著名的
So she is keen to get out and actually chronicle the war. So that Ed Murray thing that we opened with. Yeah. Did she feel that she is doing her bit for Britain's war effort? I think so. I think absolutely. Because some of her images, they're perfect for the sort of propaganda efforts, particularly for rousing people in America. So if you'd look at the Grim Glory book that you began with, the most famous
一张照片叫做《对文化的复仇》。这也是一张我想很多人可能都见过、哪怕他们没有立刻意识到那是莉·米勒拍的照片。那是一个倒塌的雕像，一根铁条横跨在雕像上，就像是在割断它的喉咙，雕像的胸部被一块掉落的砖头砸得青一块紫一块的，所以它就那样躺在废墟之中。这张照片配上《对文化的复仇》这个标题，它在某种程度上是一个影像，一个象征，象征着纳粹对西方文明的猛烈攻击。这张照片在世界范围内可以说是病毒式传播了，甚至被转载到了诸如埃及报纸等的头版头条上，它被视为纳粹野蛮行径的象征。然后还有一个故事，她做的一个专题在美国《时尚》杂志上大篇幅刊登。
photograph in there is called Revenge on Culture. And it's an image, again, that I think a lot of people may have seen, even if they don't immediately realize it was by Lee Miller it's a statue that has fallen and a kind of iron bar has has fallen across the statue as though it's cutting its throat and the breast of the statue has been kind of bruised and battered by a falling brick so it's just kind of lying amid the rubble and this photograph with the title revenge on culture it's kind of it's a it's an image a symbol of the nazi onslaught against western civilization and this went kind of viral as it were worldwide so it was even reproduced on the front pages of sort of egyptian newspapers and things and it was seen as a symbol of Nazi barbarism. Then there's a story that she did that ran as a big spread in American vogue.
那是关于女性的，也就是ATS女性（女子辅助领土服务队女性），在北伦敦操作探照灯。是的。所以离她住的地方不远。这同样是普通女性在为战争尽自己的一份力。然后她还做了一些事情，比如她在伦敦地下铁站拍摄了战时艺术家亨利·摩尔（Henry Moore）的照片，等等诸如此类。而且她还在进行实验——对于对摄影感兴趣的人来说，战争时期摄影技术取得了巨大的进步——所以出现了新的相机，比如有35
It was about women, ATS women, auxiliary territorial service women, manning a searchlight in North London. Yeah. So not far from where she lived. And again, it's like ordinary women doing their bit for the war. And then she did things like she took photographs of henry moore the war artist in london underground stations so stuff like this and she is experimenting also i mean for people who are interested in photography the war sees tremendous advances in photography so there are new cameras like a there's a 35
毫米的徕卡相机，它拥有更快的镜头和更快的感光速度，所以你可以拍摄影像，你知道的，你可以用一种在十年前或二十年前根本无法做到的方式即兴抓拍。所以她非常擅长这一点，擅长那种随性抓拍。而且她还很热衷于自己写文案。你知道的，她不想看到自己的照片被别人的文案给糟蹋了。你知道，我刚才读的那段节选，我觉得挺好的。是的，我也觉得挺好的。
millimeter leica camera which has a much faster lens and faster film speed so that you can take images, you know, you can improvise spontaneous pictures in a way that you couldn't have done 10 or 20 years earlier. So she's very good at that, at sort of taking pictures on the fly. And she's also kind of keen to write her own copy. You know, she doesn't want to see her pictures butchered by other people's copy. You know, that extract that I read, I think it's pretty good. Yeah, I think it is good.
她其实讨厌写作。她写得挺好的，但真的……这并不是自然而然的，摄影才是她与生俱来的，因为她一直跟着父亲做这件事。而且正如你所说的那样，她总是四处奔跑，听从自己的直觉。我想，你知道的，她拍照的速度越快，可能就越合她的脾气吧。完全如此。这样说公平吗？
She actually hates writing. She's quite good at it, but it's a really, it doesn't come, photography comes naturally because she's always done it with her father. And because you said this, she's always on the move, obeys her instincts. And I imagine, you know, the faster the speed at which she can take photographs, the better it suits her temperament, perhaps. Totally. Would that be fair?
我觉得绝对公平。我觉得完全就是这样，当她实际四处奔跑进行即兴抓拍时，她热爱这种状态，而且她在这方面极其出色。当她回到酒店，不得不开始打字的时候——我的意思是，她本来可以写得非常多——所以不，我可不是来批评她这么做的，但她会给《时尚》杂志发去一万字的文案来配几张照片，而他们就会觉得：这实在有点太多了，我们本来只希望有500字左右……无论如何，她真正想做的是成为一名真正的战地记者，你知道的，她已经爱上了那种工作，那给她提供了一种使命感，以及一种……她一生都在缺失的目标感。而且我认为，莉·米勒的人生中有一大悲剧，那就是她非常不安分，这是她人生的前半段一直在埃及和各种地方跟那些空调大亨厮混之类事情的原因。然后她在战争期间有了这么一个短暂的时刻，她清楚地知道自己是谁、自己想做什么。然而正如我们所看到的，战后她又变得不安分且感到无法满足了。有很多这样的人，不是吗？确实有很多。
I think that's absolutely right. I think that's exactly it that when she's actually rushing around taking photographs spontaneously she loves it and she's brilliant at it when she gets back to the hotel and she has to type i mean she ought to be massively over right so no i'm not one to criticize her for doing that but she will send vogue you know 10 000 words of copy to accompany a couple of images and they're like this is kind of too much we were hoping for about 500 um anyway what she really wants to do is to be a proper war correspondent you know she's fallen in love with that that that has given her i think a sense of mission and a sense of um a purpose that she's actually lacked all her life and i think one of the tragic things
他们在战争期间活得最淋漓尽致。绝对是的。然后战后会迎来可怕的失落感。那是一种可怕的心理落差，是的。一旦美国参战，她就获得了英国美军的记者身份认可。但她仍然相当沮丧，因为她依然被困在英国，而她渴望四处奔跑，去做一些
about lee miller's life is that she's very restless the first part of it that's why she's hanging around with the air conditioning magnets in egypt and whatnot and then she has this brief moment during the war where she knows what she who she is and what she wants to do and then as we'll see after the war she's kind of restless and unfulfilled again and there are so many people like that, aren't there? There are, absolutely. Who live at their most vivid during the war. Absolutely. And then it's a terrible come down afterwards. It's a terrible letdown, yeah. Once the US joins the war, she gets accreditation to the US forces in Britain. But she's still quite frustrated because she's still stuck in britain and she wants to be kind of on the move and doing
激动人心的事情。然后1944年6月的诺曼底登陆发生了，这真的成为了她的转折点。欧洲的解放是她的职业生涯真正大放异彩的时刻。对于她来说，回到那个她曾经生活得如此快乐的法国——这种感觉一定非常非常强烈，就像海明威经历的那样，对吧？如果是在别的地方，就不会有那种共鸣了。因为她会说那门语言。她在那里有很多朋友。而且正如我们所将看到的，我的意思是，她的许多朋友都有过可怕的经历。
exciting things and then d-day happens in june 1944 and that really is her break the liberation of europe is the moment where her career really comes alive and for her going back to france where she'd been so happy i mean it must be very very intense in the way it is say for hemingway yeah if it was somewhere else it wouldn't have the kind of resonance. Because she speaks the language. She's got lots of friends there. Yeah. And as we'll see, I mean, lots of her friends have had terrible experiences.
是的。她的法国朋友们。是的。所以这对她来说是非常个人化的。但在她去法国之前——所以她先是在7月过去，她被派去执行一项任务，报道诺曼底的美军野战医院，因为当然，诺曼底的战事即使在登陆日之后也极其血腥。她在那里待了五天，拍了35卷胶卷，写了一万字，然后她把这些
Yeah. Her French friends. Yeah. So it's really personal for her. But before she goes to France, so she goes over first in July and she goes to, she's sent on an assignment to cover US Army field hospitals in Normandy because of course the battle in Normandy is incredibly bloody even after D-Day and she's there for five days and she takes 35 rolls of film and she writes 10,000 words and she gives
交给了《时尚》杂志，他们震惊了。他们根本没料到会有这样的内容，并把它们作为双跨页刊登在了下一期的九月刊上。从那一刻起，她就像是找到了生命的意义。她甚至改变了自己的着装方式——所以所有那种时髦的、20世纪30年代的上流社会造型，全都消失了。是的，她穿着类似作战服的衣服，为自己吃着和军人一样的口配给而感到自豪，坐在周围打牌，那种……你知道的，几乎就像是战争的日常，漫长的无聊被突如其来的行动所打破，她热爱这一切，美国大兵的那种世界，显然很合她的脾气。是的，绝对如此。
this to Vogue and they are stunned they weren't expecting anything like this and they run it in two double page spreads in the next issue in the september issue and from that point onwards it's like she's found her meaning she even changes the way she dresses so all the sort of the stylish you know 1930s high society look that's all gone yeah she wears kind of battle dress you know prides herself on eating the same rations as the servicemen on kind of sitting around playing cards and that kind of you know almost like the routine of the war the the long stretches of boredom interspersed with sudden activity she loves all that that kind of world that the gi's it suits her temperament clearly yeah it absolutely does.
她设法争取到了去报道圣马洛战事的协议。而事实上，此时同盟国正在向公众宣传圣马洛已经被攻克了。但她到了那里却发现根本没有这回事。基本上，德国人全都龟缩在这个城堡里。而美军第83步兵师、美国陆军第83步兵师正在进行一场极其凶猛且残酷的战斗来攻克它。所以你刚才读的那段，就是她身处战斗最激烈的核心。
And she wangles this deal to go and cover what's going on in San Marlo. And actually, at this point, the Allies are kind of telling their public that San Marlo has been taken. But she gets there and she finds out it hasn't at all. Basically, the Germans are all in this citadel. And the US 83rd Division, US Army 83rd Division, are fighting this ferocious and incredibly brutal battle to get it. And so that bit that you read is her kind of in the thick of the action.
人们在她身边纷纷倒下。但我在书中发现的真正令人震惊的事情是，美国空军正在使用凝固汽油弹。这是持续使用凝固汽油弹的最早实例之一。电影里拍得太棒了，多米尼克。是吗？是的，我的意思是，我可以想象那会非常壮观。而她，你知道的，拍摄了照片，
People are dropping dead around her. But also the really shocking thing I discovered from the book, the U.S. Air Force are using napalm. It's one of the first instances of the sustained use of napalm. Brilliantly done in the film, Dominic. Is it? Yeah, I mean, I can imagine it would be incredibly spectacular. And she, you know, takes photographs
并把这写了下来。因为我根本不知道当时那么早就已经开始使用凝固汽油弹了。不，我也不知道。我太傻了，只因为我把它和越南联系起来，我便想当然了。但不是的，伦敦的审查员删掉了她所有关于使用凝固汽油弹的照片，因为可以理解的是，他们觉得这对我们的战争努力来说是非常糟糕的宣传。实际上，由于她超越了指令——也就是当她本该去记录恢复平民秩序的工作时，她却跑进了
and she writes about this. Because I had no idea napalm was being used that early. No, I didn't. I foolishly, just because I associated it with Vietnam, I just assumed. But no, the censors in London took out all her shots of the napalm being used because understandably they were like this is very bad publicity for our for our war efforts and actually because she had exceeded her instructions so she had gone into the
作战区——她实际上惹上了麻烦，并被暂时软禁在雷恩。英国秘密情报局难道不担心她可能也是个共产党人或者为苏联工作吗？这是真的还是假的？我不确定
combat zone when she was meant to have been chronicling the restoration of civil order she actually gets in trouble and she gets temporarily put under house arrest in ren don't the british secret service worry that she might be communist as well or working for the of civil order. She actually gets in trouble and she gets temporarily put under house arrest in Wren. Don't the British Secret Service worry that she might be communist as well or working for the Soviets? Is that true or not? I'm not sure
这是否属实，说实话。我没有看到，至少在她儿子的传记中，没有任何证据表明这一点。我看到过……我想发生的情况是，我读过关于她的名字出现在档案里、出现在名单上的新闻报道。但我想这只是……这并不像查理·卓别林被拒绝重新入境美国之类的事情。当然，她确实结交过一些相当左翼的人，也许方式没有你的奥本海默之类的人那么公开。
that is true, actually. I haven't seen, certainly in the biography by her son, there's no evidence of that. I have seen, I think what's happened is I've read newspaper reports
我的意思是，当你跟超现实主义巴黎沙龙里那些画着蓝色身体的桂格教徒厮混在一起时，汤姆，这就会成为一种职业风险。但我不认为这在很大程度上阻碍了她或者别的什么。因为反正她很快就被放出来了，她去巴黎参加解放仪式。而她那些超现实主义的朋友们也纷纷从他们过去几年一直躲藏的工作室里
about her name being in files, being in a list. But I think it's just, it's not like Charlie Chaplin being refused a re-entry to the United States or whatever it was. Right. Obviously, she has associated, perhaps in a less overt way than your Oppenheimers or something, she's associated with some pretty left-wing people.
冒了出来。当他们看到这个女人时，真的大吃一惊。是的，这个历经风雨、充满口音的女人。这还是那个曾经……你知道的，打扮得如此时髦、热衷于各种有趣但同样是莉·米勒的那个女人吗？当她遇到她的一些朋友时，发现他们也发生了彻底的改变。所以我们提到了索朗热，那位……巴黎上流社会的贵族核心，是的。她在1942年被盖世太保逮捕了，因为她的丈夫——第八代奈公爵的儿子——曾参加抵抗运动，并且遭到了匿名举报。
I mean, that's what happens when you hang around with blue-painted Quakers in the salons of surrealist Paris, Tom. It's a kind of occupational hazard. But I don't think it massively holds her back or anything. Because she's let out again anyway, she gets to Paris for the liberation. And all her kind of surrealist pals are kind of surfacing from their studios
于是他被送往了贝尔森集中营，并在那里的解放前几天死去了。她被关押了很长一段时间，莉·米勒找到了她，她说（你知道的），她已经变得面目全非——尽管她后来确实回去了，战后还在《时尚》杂志工作，并且成为了特兰托克洛里埃等地方的名流。所以，同样地，我的意思是，这是一个很好的例子，说明这些看似生活得如此养尊处优、如此奢华的人，他们其实是影响着数百万人的更广泛社会政治变革的化身。总之，她当时在巴黎。而事实上，可悲的是，她一直深爱着巴黎，认为这里棒极了，诸如此类。但事实上，现在，特别是经历了圣马洛之后，她反而觉得这里太温和了。她现在已经对
where they've been hiding away for the last few years. And they're really astounded when they see this woman. Yeah, this hard-boiled woman of accent. Is this the same lee miller who was kind of you know looking so stylish and getting up to all kinds of amusing but equally lee miller when she meets some of her friends finds them utterly changed as well so we mentioned solange the um the aristocrat you know the aristocratic epicenter of parisian life yeah and she had been arrested by the gestapo in 1942 because her husband the son of the eighth duke of nye had been in the resistance and there'd been an anonymous denunciation yeah and so he got sent off to belson where he died
战斗的肾上腺素飙升以及恐怖等等事情上瘾了。如果你读过某些战地记者的回忆录，他们就会说，一开始他们是如何感到惊恐，并觉得这一切如此令人震惊，但后来这变成了一种强迫性的事情。我不会，你不会，绝不，对吧？我喜欢你把自己也括进去了。你知道的，你给人一种你曾和战地记者生活擦出一点火花的印象。好吧，某种程度上。我的意思是，你知道的，深入伊斯兰国的大本营，
just a few days before the uh before its liberation and she was in prison a good long time and lee miller found her she said you know she'd been terribly changed although she does I mean she goes back and then works in vogue after the war and yeah becomes a luminary of the trontocloriers and all that so well again I mean it's a good example of these people whose lives maybe seem so pampered and so luxurious they are embodiments of wider social kind of political changes that are affecting millions of people anyway she's there in paris and actually the sad thing is that she'd always loved paris and thought it was brilliant and all that stuff but actually now especially after sam arlo she actually finds it too tame she hasn't she's now addicted to the
当时他们到处抓捕西方人并砍下他们的头。我当时想，不，我太懦弱了，干不了这个。你回来了，反而跟我一起做播客。这真是一言难尽，不是吗？这才是真正的勇气。所以她加入了这个行列，基本上报名作为美国陆军的嵌入式摄影师随军出发，
adrenaline rush of you know combat and the horror and all that kind of thing and this is something that if you've ever read memoirs some war correspondents they will say how at first they're horrified and they find it so shocking but it becomes a kind of compulsive thing not for me not for you never again right i like how you're bracketing yourself there. You know, you're giving the impression you had a little flirtation with a life as a war correspondent. Well, kind of. I mean, you know, going into the Islamic State heartlands
和她的这个朋友、另一位摄影师、一位非常优秀的摄影师戴夫·谢尔曼（Dave Sherman）一起。整个1944年末到1945年期间，他们一直在穿梭——对于一个来自纽约上流社会的人来说，我的意思是，这是一个末日般的场景：道路被堵塞，难民四处逃难，村庄被炸毁，到处都是尸体，下着倾盆大雨，满地都是泥泞，战斗不断。但最糟糕的还在后面，不是吗？是的，战斗不断，而且她居然乐在其中。我的意思是，说出这话感觉很奇怪，因为这显然是极其可怕的。
when they're all hanging and rushing around capturing Westerners and chopping off their heads. I just thought, no, I'm too cowardly for this. He came back and did a podcast with me instead. That says it all, doesn't it? That's true courage. So she joins this, basically signs up to go along as an embedded photographer of the US Army
而且她也对这种恐怖景象发表了评论。但我想她感受到了目标感。是的。如果你读她的文字，我认为她的散文捕捉到了那种诡异的——我不知道“感官性”是不是合适的词——战争恐怖的感官性。她谈到了颜色、声音以及所有这些东西。但她现在拥有的相机，可以让她以一种技术上以前无法做到的速度非常迅速地拍照。
with this friend of hers, another photographer, a very good photographer called Dave Sherman. And all through kind of late 1944, 1945, they are moving through, for somebody from, you know, high society New York, I i mean this is an apocalyptic scene the roads choked the refugees villages bombed out bodies everywhere it's pouring with rain there's mud constant fighting but the worst is yet to come isn't it yeah constant fighting and she is loving it in a way i mean that's a weird thing to say because obviously it's horrible.
所以在某种意义上，她一定觉得她有能力把前线的情况带给后方的人们，这种形式在历史上是从来没有实现过的。是的，我认为是这样的。她有两台相机，所以她一直在用两台相机不停地拍，因为她一卷胶卷只有12张，而她绝不想错过任何东西，所以她拍了大量大量的照片。我同意，这些照片以一种甚至可以说是连在第一次世界大战中都非常、非常难以做到的方式，捕捉到了战争的恐怖。
And she says she comments on the horror. But she feels a purpose, I suppose. Yeah. And if you read her writing, I think her prose captures this kind of weird, I don't know whether sensuousness is the right word, the sensuousness of the horror of war. She talks about the colors and the sound and all that stuff. But the kind of camera she now has, she can take photographs very rapidly in a way that technologically hadn't been possible before.
当然，甚至在最早的那些现代战争中——克里米亚战争、美国内战之类的事情——几乎是不可能做到的。甚至她写作的方式，都带有一种视觉质感。“我再也不会看到那种酸黄色和灰色了，就像炮弹在雪地中炸开时那样，同时我也不会看到那些新兵苍白颤抖的面孔，他们因恐惧而呈现出灰色和黄色，他们笨拙的手，以及对他们必须穿过的田野投去的鬼祟的、短视的目光。”她描写那种布满弹坑、
And so in that sense, she must feel that she is in a position to bring home to people away from the front what it looks like in a way that simply hadn't been possible before ever in history yeah i think that's true she has two cameras so she's taking with two shots all the time because she has 12 shots on a roll and she never wants to miss anything so she's taking loads and loads of photographs and i agree the photographs are capturing the horror of war in a way that even arguably in the first world war you you know, it'd been very, very difficult to do.
千疮百孔的战场等等的方式，你知道的，她在摄影和超现实主义艺术方面的训练，以一种奇怪的方式为她做好了面对这一切的准备。所以，多米尼克，我们现在来到了可能——我的意思是，她将看到的最大的恐怖，以及她最为著名的那些照片。是的，也就是她在达豪集中营拍的照片。是的。对此有一种感觉，不是吗？那就是这种恐怖几乎大到连散文都无法应对了。因此，摄影的作用变得——我的意思是，其重要性可以说是具有颠覆性的。
Certainly in even the very first kind of modern wars, the Crimean war, the US civil war, something it had been almost impossible to do. And even the way she writes, there's a visual quality to it. I'll never see acid yellow and gray again, like where shells burst in the snow without seeing also the pale quivering faces of the replacements, grey and yellow with apprehension, their fumbling hands and furtive, short-sighted glances at the fields they must cross. And the way she writes about the kind of the pitted,
我认为这至关重要，因为当然，记录德国人和纳粹所作所为的现实，在去纳粹化过程中是如此重要，这种理念就是你必须向人们展示现实，仅仅靠文字描述是不够的，你必须展示而不是讲述，所以你需要证据，不是吗？是的，你确实需要证据，因为人们不会相信他们被告知的事情。
cratered battlefield and stuff, it is, you know, the training in photography and surrealist art has kind of prepared her for all that in a weird way. And so, Dominic, we come now to probably, I mean, the greatest horror that she will see and the photographs for which perhaps she's most famous yeah which is the photos that she takes in dachau yeah and there is a sense with that isn't there that the horror is almost too great for pros to cope with. Yeah. Therefore, the role of photography becomes, I mean, seismically important.
记住，达豪不是犹太人大屠杀的灭绝营，达豪是一个集中营，是第三帝国成立初期建立的第一批集中营之一。它在慕尼黑郊外，所以位于纳粹的大本营。它于1945年4月29日被解放。她和她的朋友兼同事戴夫·谢尔曼是第一批被允许进入集中营的新闻记者。这里到处都是尸体。有39节装满尸体的铁路车厢。那些在营地里仍然活着的人生活在难以想象的肮脏环境中，饱受霍乱和斑疹伤寒的折磨，骨瘦如柴。我的意思是，人间炼狱这种说法简直是个陈词滥调。
I think it's massively important because, of course, documenting the reality of what the Germans had done and what the Nazis had done was so important in the denazification process and the idea that you have to show people the reality and merely describing it is not enough you have to you have to show not tell so you need proof don't you you yeah you need proof exactly because people won't believe what they're being told exactly
这种说法根本无法形容它的万分之一，实际上只有照片才能真正展现其全貌。许多摄影师都当场呕吐了。他们甚至很难去拍下这些照片。她做到了。这种人间炼狱的说法简直是个陈词滥调，它根本无法形容其万分之一，实际上只有照片才能真正展现其全貌。许多摄影师都当场呕吐了。他们甚至很难去拍下这些照片。她做到了，并且把带有这些照片的电报发回了《时尚》杂志——我的意思是，这些照片竟然是发给《时尚》杂志的奥黛丽·威瑟斯的，对吧？安德丽娅·赖斯伯勒在电影里演的好像就是她，对吧？你刚才提到的。事实证明，这竟然是发给《时尚》杂志的，这就显得更加格格不入且骇人听闻。她说：“我恳求你们相信这是真的，”因为很显然她知道人们无论如何都不会相信。他们去了达豪，正如我所说，它就在慕尼黑郊外。她和李进入了慕尼黑，他们基本上找了个地方（你知道的，到处都是士兵，美国陆军什么的，许多人涌入这座城市）。他们在这些公寓中找了一个落脚点，有大量的公寓被接管了。那是在摄政王广场（Prince Regent Square）27号。正如她儿子的传记中所说，这看起来是个非常正派的地方。它看起来就像是一个商人或退休牧师住的地方。当他们进去时，他们看到银器上全都印着这个缩写字母——A·H，
remember dachau is not a holocaust extermination camp dachau is a concentration camp one of the first set up after the beginning of the Third Reich. It's outside Munich, so it's in the kind of Nazi heartland. It was liberated on the 29th of April, 1945. She and Dave Sherman, her friend and colleague, they're in the first group of pressmen who are allowed into the camp. And the place is littered with bodies. So there were 39 railway cars full of dead bodies. Those people who are still alive in the camp are living in unimaginable squalor, riddled with cholera and typhus and utterly emaciated. I mean, it's a vision of hell is such a cliche.
到处都是纳粹卐字旗。这就是阿道夫·希特勒在慕尼黑的旧公寓，当他在柏林、狼穴等地时，他一直保留着这里。这就是他在咖啡馆等地方与尤妮蒂·米特福德（Unity Mitford）见面时鬼混的地方。没错，是的。哦，天哪。我真不敢相信你竟然把尤妮蒂·米特福德也硬塞进来了。
It doesn't do it justice. Only the photographs do it justice, actually. And a lot of the photographers are physically sick. They struggle to even take the photos. She does it. of hell is such a cliche it doesn't do it justice only the photographs do it justice actually and a lot of the photographers are physically sick they struggle to even take the photos she does it and she sends this telegram with the photos back to vogue i mean the fact that they're being sent to vogue to audrey withers isn't it in london yeah andrea riseborough i think in the film isn't it you were saying yeah the fact that it's in vogue makes it all the more incongruous and horrific and she says i implore you to believe this is true because obviously she knows people
这真是教科书级别的霍兰德式操作。现在，这就是许多人见过的照片。她走进浴缸洗了个澡。她洗澡的原因并不是因为这是希特勒的浴缸。而是因为她身上沾满了泥。达豪的泥。达豪的泥，是的，你说的对。戴夫拍下了一张照片，照片里她把靴子放在浴缸前，
won't believe it anyway they've been to dachau and as i said it's just outside munich she and lee go into munich and they basically find a place you know there are soldiers everywhere u.s army whatever lots of people pouring into city. They find a billet in one of these apartments, loads of apartments being taken over. And it's at Prince Regent Square, number 27. And as her son's biography says, it seems like a very respectable place. It looks like a merchant or a retired clergyman lives there. And when they get in, they see that on the silver, it's all embossed with this monogram, A-H,
她正从浴缸里探出头来。当然，现在如果你在谷歌上搜索莉·米勒，你经常会看到这张照片，因为人们对这位女性先锋摄影师泡在希特勒浴缸里的这种不合时宜感到震惊。我的意思是，我认为这是每个人对她的唯一了解，甚至可能比那些达豪集中营的照片还要著名。但有趣的是，在那时，这并不是真正吸引人们眼球的照片，或者说当时是吗？不是的。所以当时那张照片并没有引起轰动，人们当时也不是都知道它。真正 viral（病毒式传播）的照片是一张他们摆拍的照片，他们让一个美国大兵躺在希特勒的旧床上读《我的奋斗》，一只手还拿着电话。戴夫拍下了这张照片，它登上了《生活》杂志，并引起了巨大、巨大的轰动。希特勒浴缸的那张照片是什么时候变得像现在这么著名的？我想直到莉·米勒本人成名之后，它才变得出名。没错。而莉·米勒直到她儿子在20世纪80年代出版这本传记时才成名。因为正如我们所将看到的，实际上，如果我们把这个播客放在20世纪70年代或60年代录制，根本没有人会听说过她。她被遗忘了，而这本身就是一个有趣的故事。
and there's swastikas everywhere. And it is Adolf Hitler's old apartment, which he had maintained in Munich while he was off in Berlin and the Wolf's Lair and all this. This is where he'd been hanging out when he was meeting up with Unity Mitford in the cafes and things. Right, yes. Oh, my word. I can't believe you've shoehorned Unity Mitford.
所以他们去了爱娃·布朗（Ava Brown）的公寓，李在爱娃·布朗的床上小睡了一会儿。然后他们去了贝格霍夫（Berghof），也就是“鹰巢”，希特勒的那个山间避暑胜地。它正在被摧毁。它被美国陆军夷为平地。而且有相当多的掠夺行为，可以理解，人们都在拿纪念品。所以戴夫拿走了
That is textbook Holland. Now, this is the image that lots of people have seen. She gets into the bath and has a bath. And the reason she has a bath is not because it's Hitler's bath. It's because she's covered with mud. The mud of Dachau. The mud of Dachau, yeah, you're right. And Dave takes a photograph of her with her boots in front of the bath and she's
德文译本的《莎士比亚全集》，上面带有希特勒的藏书票。所以那是希特勒藏书版的……好吧，他是犹太人，不是吗？所以，你知道的，这对他来说更加个人化。而李拿走了希特勒的酒盘，她一直把这个留着……而且可以想见，这个家族至今仍保留着希特勒的银制餐具。嗯，如果你看了电影，里面就有这个情节。那太棒了。战争在那之后几天就结束了。她在儿子的传记中说，这是莉·米勒人生的巨大反高潮，因为在那之后，她失去了那种在极短时间内曾拥有过的、美妙珍贵却又令人毛骨悚然的目标感。她仍然在为《时尚》杂志等机构做一些事情。这是一个很好的例子，说明那是多么大的反高潮：他们给她的下一个任务是
looking out of the bath and of course this is the photo you'll often see now when you google lee miller because people are struck by the incongruity of this pioneering female photographer in hitler's bath i mean it's the one thing i think that that everyone will know about her maybe even more than the the dachau photographs but the interesting thing is that wasn't the photograph that really caught people's attention at the time or was it not no so at the time that photograph is not a great sensation and people don't all know about it at the time the photograph that goes viral as it were it's a shot they set up which is if they get a gi and they get him to lie on hitler's old bed reading mein kampf and with the telephone in one hand. And Dave took it and it
去丹麦，你知道的，去拍摄照片，展示现在战争结束后丹麦的一切是如何恢复正常的。当然，本质上这完全不一样，对吧？这是一个如此无聊的故事。你知道的，丹麦人又在买鞋子之类的，我的意思是，这根本不令人兴奋。与此同时，多米尼克，罗兰怎么样了呢？因为我们提到他其实经历了一段非常有趣的战时生活，因为他是一名兵役拒服者，所以显然他没有参军，但他利用自己对视觉艺术的精通，成为了萨里郡法纳姆城堡（Farnham Castle）迷彩开发与培训中心的资深讲师。而且，
was in Life magazine and it was a huge, huge sensation. When did the Hitler bath one become as famous as it has become? I think it didn't become famous until Lee Miller became famous. Right. And Lee Miller didn't become famous until her son published this biography in the 1980s. Okay. Because as we will see, actually, if we'd done this podcast in the 1970s or 60s, nobody would have really heard of it. She was forgotten, which is an interesting story in and of itself.
他有一张莉·米勒画着迷彩的彩色照片，并用这张照片作为说明，展示你可以做些什么来伪装事物，因为她在照片中是赤身裸体的。是的。而且她身上覆盖着这种迷彩网。他把这张照片拿给他的学生看。他说：“如果我能用迷彩隐藏我朋友李的迷人之处，那么你们就能隐藏任何东西。”当然。所以他们当时还没有结婚。
So they go to Ava Brown's apartment and Lee has a nap on Ava Brown's bed. They then go out to the Berghof, the Eagle's Nest, Hitler's kind of mountain retreat. And it's being destroyed. It's razed to the ground by the US Army. And there's a fair amount of looting understandably people are taking souvenirs so dave takes um the complete works of
对，他们没有结婚。他们只是好朋友。她当时依然嫁给了阿齐兹先生。当然，还有他的空调。是的。我的意思是，天知道他后来怎么样了。在她返回汉普斯特德、回到北伦敦之前，你可以看到她正试图重新点燃那种冒险精神。如果你想想那种类似《第三人》中维也纳的场景，
shakespeare in translation with hitler's book plate so hitler's copy of the complete well he's jewish isn't he so yeah um you know it's all the more personal for him and lee took um hitler's drinks tray which she kept for the and presumably the family still have hitler's silver well if you see the film it features well that's great so the war ends just a few days after that and her son in his biography says this was the great anti-climax of lee's life because after that point she has lost that wonderful precious but also horrifying sense of purpose that she had for that brief period of time she still is doing stuff for vogue and whatnot this is a good example of how what anti-climax it was the next assignment they
被炸毁、遭到重创、满目疮痍。而且我想铁幕也开始降临了。完全是那些。所以她去了维也纳，去了布达佩斯，她甚至还去拍摄了那个法西斯合作主义首相的处决过程。她接着去了罗马尼亚，汤姆。她在那里被一只跳舞的熊按摩了。真的吗？怎么会发生这种事？她背部非常痛，因为她一直睡在地上，跟士兵们一起旅行。她在罗马尼亚遇到了某个人，对方说：“哦，你背痛啊。治背痛只有一个方法，
gave her they said go to Denmark and um you know take photographs showing how everything's going back to normal in Denmark now the war is over of course intrinsically that's not the same is it it's such a boring story yeah you know danish people are buying shoes again or whatever i mean it's not exciting and meanwhile dominic what about uh roland because we mentioned that he actually has a very interesting war because he's a conscientious objector so obviously he he's not in the army but he using his mastery of the visual arts he becomes senior lecturer at the camouflage development and training center at farnham castle in surrey yeah and um he has this color photograph of lee miller kind of painted in camouflage and uh kind of uses this as illustration of what you
那就是让跳舞的熊给你按个摩。”她居然真的去找了……当时罗马尼亚政府曾试图取缔跳舞的熊，因为他们说那是落后的象征。什么，所以把它们重新培训成按摩理疗师吗？不是。不，按摩本来就是跳舞熊的保留节目之一。哦，我明白了。
can do yeah to disguise things because she's naked in the photograph. Yeah. And she's covered with this camouflage net. And he shows it to his students. And he says, if I can hide my friend Lee's charms with camouflage, then you can hide anything. Of course. So they're not married at this point.
可以，是的，用来掩饰，因为她在照片里是赤裸的。是的，她身上盖着这层伪装网。他把这张照片拿给他的学生们看，并且说：如果我能用伪装掩盖我朋友李的迷人之处，那么你们就能掩盖任何东西。当然。所以这时候他们还没结婚。
No, they're not married. They're just good friends. She's married to Mr. Aziz still. Of course, with his air conditioning. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, God knows what's been going on with him. before she goes back to hamstead to north london you can see she's trying to rekindle the spirit of adventure if you think of that sort of third man you know vienna yeah bombed out
不，他们还没结婚。他们只是好朋友。她依然嫁给了阿齐兹先生。当然，还有他的空调。是的。是的。我是说，上帝才知道他那边发生了什么。在她返回北伦敦的汉普斯特德之前，你可以看到她正试图重燃冒险精神，如果你联想起那种《第三人》里的维也纳，你知道的，被炸毁的
battered ravaged yeah and also i suppose the iron curtain starting to come down exactly all that so she goes to vienna she goes to budapest and she actually photographs the execution of the kind of fascist collaborationist prime minister she goes on into romania there tom uh she is massaged by a dancing bear really how did that happen she has a very bad back because she's been sleeping on the ground, traveling with the soldiers. And she meets somebody in Romania and they say, well, you've got a bad back. There's only one cure for a bad back,
饱受摧残、满目疮痍的。是的，而且我想铁幕也开始降临了，完全就是这样。所以她去了维也纳，去了布达佩斯，她甚至拍摄了那个法西斯合作主义首相的处刑过程。接着她去了罗马尼亚，汤姆。她竟然被一头跳舞的熊按摩过。真的吗？怎么会这样？她背部很不舒服，因为她一直睡在地上，跟随士兵们四处奔波。她在罗马尼亚遇到了一些人，他们对她说：哦，你背不好。治疗背痛只有一个方法，
and that's to be massaged by a dancing bear. And she actually finds... Now, the Romanian government had tried to outlaw dancing bears because they said it was a symbol of backwardness. What, so retrain them as massage therapists? No. No, the massage was always part of the dancing bear repertoire. Oh, I see.
那就是让跳舞的熊给你按摩。而她居然真的找到……当时，罗马尼亚政府曾试图取缔跳舞的熊，因为他们认为那是落后的象征。什么，难道要重新训练它们当按摩师吗？不。不，按摩本来就是跳舞的熊的绝活之一。哦，原来如此。
Anyway, she finds this village and there's this bloke who's a Romany guy and he's got a dancing bear. And she gets the bear to massage her. And she wrote afterwards, the bear knew her business. She walked up and down my back on all fours as gently as if on eggs. And there's music playing. So the bloke's obviously playing some like violin or something. As the music started, she raised up on her high legs and shuffled up and down my back.
总之，她找到了这个村子，里面有个罗姆人小伙，他有一头会跳舞的熊。然后她让这头熊给她按摩。她后来写道，这头熊很懂行。它四脚着地、像走在鸡蛋上一样轻柔地在她背上上下走动。当时还有音乐在响。所以那个小伙子显然在拉小提琴什么的。音乐一响，它就用后腿站起来，在她背上晃悠。
It was crushing and exhilarating. She said it was brilliant. It fixed her back. So if you've ever got a bad back, Tom. Right. Remember this. Get hold of a bear. Yeah.
这种感觉既震撼又令人振奋。她说这简直棒极了。它治好了她的背。所以汤姆，如果你以后背痛的话。没错。记住这个。去抓头熊。对。
Have you ever seen a dancing bear? No, I've never seen a dancing bear. I hobnobbed with a dancing bear at the Kaprischitz Folk Festival in Bulgaria. Did you? When I was backpacking. Yeah. Well, I mean, this is quite a theme that we could perhaps do an episode on, is dancing bears in the Second World War.
你见过会跳舞的熊吗？没有，我从未见过会跳舞的熊。我在保加利亚的卡普里希茨民俗节上和一个跳舞的熊交谈过。真的吗？当我背包客旅行的时候。对。我的意思是，这其实是一个很好的主题，我们也许可以做一期节目，那就是第二次世界大战中的跳舞熊。
Because, of course, there's a very famous Polish bear who gets rescued. Oh, it's a Wojtek. Wojtek, who ended up having swims in in the river tweed directly below my scottish estate wow so he's he's very big in our neighborhood see even though we've done monkeys and dogs yeah we should do bears bears would be a great subject anyway dominic we're going off piste yeah basically she's rushing around she's trying to to get her adrenaline kick yeah try and relive old glories but she doesn't. The war is over. So how does she end up married to Roland Penrose?
因为，当然，有一头非常著名的波罗的海（应为波兰）熊被救了。哦，那是沃伊泰克。沃伊泰克，它最后在苏格兰庄园正下方的特威德河里游泳，哇，所以在我们附近它非常有名，你看，虽然我们已经讲过猴子和狗了，对，我们应该讲讲熊，熊会是一个很棒的主题。不管怎样，多米尼克，我们有点跑题了。对，基本上她四处奔波，试图寻求肾上腺素的刺激，试图重温过去的辉煌，但她没有。战争已经结束了。那么她是怎么最终嫁给罗兰·彭罗斯的呢？
Because she does, doesn't she? That's, I mean, they end up married and they live and die as a couple. She effectively has a breakdown in Bucharest. She gets all the way to Bucharest and she has a breakdown. She can't keep writing. She's run out of money. She's actually run out of options. She's gone almost, as it were, to the end of the line in an attempt to try and recapture this spirit of excitement.
因为她确实嫁了，不是吗？我的意思是，他们最终结为夫妻，作为伴侣共同生活到老。她在布加勒斯特彻底崩溃了。她一路走到布加勒斯特，然后崩溃了。她无法再写作了。她花光了钱。她实际上已经山穷水尽了。她几乎可以说是走到了绝路，试图重新找回那种兴奋的激情。
And Dave, her old pal, says, you know, you've been ignoring Roland's letters. I think you should just go back to him now. And that's actually the one thing that she doesn't want to do is to settle down. She's never settled down all her life. I mean, the whole point of her is that she's this kind of free spirit but she has no other option so she goes back to hampstead roland who i have to say comes out of this incredibly well she's been ignoring all his letters and stuff but she says i'm back now and he says great well you know welcome home they have a son anthony they get married roland it's all brilliant for him he's been a tremendous hit with his camouflage in the war yeah yeah he fans the Institute for Contemporary Art he does loads of stuff for the British Council he becomes a big star of the arts world he ends up getting knighted
而她老朋友戴夫说，你知道的，你一直不理罗兰的信。我觉得你现在应该回到他身边去。而这其实是她最不想做的事，那就是安定下来。她一生从未安定过。我的意思是，她的全部意义就在于她是个自由不羁的灵魂，但她别无选择，所以她回到了汉普斯特德找罗兰。我不得不说，罗兰在这件事上表现得极其大度。她之前一直不回他的信什么的，但她说我现在回来了，而他说太好了，你知道的，欢迎回家。他们生了一个儿子安东尼，他们结婚了。罗兰，对他来说这一切都太棒了，他在战争中的迷彩伪装取得了巨大的成功，对，对，他创立了当代艺术协会，他为英国文化协会做了大量工作，他成为了艺术界的大明星，最后还被封为爵士。
so it's onwards and upwards for him and some people may well say this is the classic story the man succeeds and the woman you know unbelievably talented in her own way is just forgotten which is exactly what happens because she's very she's empty she's depressed it's such a classic war correspondent story and they end up in a farm in sussex that's right full of picasso and hitler's drinks tray so but picasso is kind of coming over isn't he yeah all her old surrealist and artist friends from Paris are always coming over to this farmhouse in Sussex. And she's kind of rustling them up.
所以对他来说是蒸蒸日上，有些人可能会说这是一个经典的故事：男人成功了，而那个女人——以她自己的方式拥有难以置信的天赋——却被遗忘了，而这正是所发生的事情，因为她非常空虚，她很沮丧，这是一个典型的战地记者故事。他们最终在苏塞克斯的一个农场安顿下来，没错，里面装满了毕加索和希特勒的酒盘。所以毕加索经常过来，对吧？对，她所有来自巴黎的超现实主义艺术家朋友都经常来苏塞克斯的这个农场。而她一直在为他们张罗。
Weird kind of deep fried marshmallows or something like that. Yeah. So here's the interesting thing. She was a terrific photographer. And in the 1940s, her photographs had been sensations across the world and had been some of the defining images of the second world war but by the 1950s or 1960s that is completely forgotten and not least because she herself almost willfully tries to put it all behind her and to say it happened to somebody else who's long gone and all this kind of thing so So, yes, she's doing all this cooking and she's, you know,
奇怪的油炸棉花糖或类似的东西。对。所以有趣的地方在于：她是一位出色的摄影师。在20世纪40年代，她的照片曾在全世界引起轰动，并成为第二次世界大战中最具代表性的影像之一。但到了20世纪50年代或60年代，这一切都被彻底遗忘了，很大程度上是因为她自己几乎是有意地将这一切抛在脑后，并声称那是发生在早已离去的另一个人身上的事，诸如此类。所以，是的，她一直在做饭，她，你知道的，
basically almost like a housewife. That's what she is. But she's also drinking very heavily. Yeah, drinking very heavily. Piling on the pounds. Yeah, her sun paints are very unsparing. Well, you've got it here. I mean, her face no longer had its fineness.
基本上就像个家庭主妇。这就是她现在的样子。但她也酗酒非常厉害。对，酗酒非常厉害。体重飙升。对，她儿子的回忆录非常毫不留情。你看，你这里有。我的意思是，她的脸不再精致了。
Wrinkles and folds were proliferating and her eyes were becoming puffy. Her hair was getting thinner and lifeless. The fat was piling on, making her body look coarse and bulky. To make matters worse, the woman who had once been described as a snappy dresser was fast becoming a slob. I mean, that's no way to write about your mother, is it? Tom, if your own heirs write that about you one day you'd be very upset you'd be very upset right i think it's a really it's actually a very sad story and the saddest element of it for me is that she puts all her cameras in the cupboard never takes them out again she
皱纹和褶皱不断增多，她的眼睛也变得浮肿。她的头发越来越稀疏，毫无生气。脂肪不断堆积，使她的身材看起来粗糙而笨重。更糟糕的是，这个曾被描述为穿着时髦的女人正迅速变成一个邋遢鬼。我的意思是，怎么能这样写自己的母亲呢？汤姆，如果你的后代有一天这样写你，你会非常生气的，你会非常生气的，对吧？我觉得这真的是一个非常悲伤的故事，而对我来说最悲伤的部分是，她把所有的相机都锁在柜子里，再也没有拿出来过，她
refuses to take photographs again i mean she won't even take family photographs so people will say to her come on you love photography photography is your. You're actually one of the world's great photographers. But you can see that. I am reminded of Sir Geoffrey Boycott, the great England opening batsman, who, when he retired from cricket, put away his bat and has never picked it up since. Right. Well, that's the parallel that will immediately have occurred to him. You know, if you've played against the greatest bowlers, you don't want to be arsing around
拒绝再拍照。我的意思是，她甚至不肯拍家庭照片。所以人们会对她说：得了吧，你热爱摄影，摄影就是你的。你实际上是世界上最伟大的摄影师之一。但你可以看出这一点。这让我想起了杰弗里·博伊考特爵士，这位伟大的英格兰开场击球手，他在从板球界退役后，就收起了球棒，再也没有拿起来过。没错。好吧，这会是人们立刻想到的类比。你知道的，如果你和最伟大的投手交过手，你就不想在
on the village green. Yeah. And it may be the same kind of idea. But the interesting thing is that Geoffrey Boycott, Tom, was never one to downplay his own achievements. No, that's true. That's true. But Lee Miller, people go to her and they say, I understand you were a great photographer in the Second World War. I would really love to see your negatives.
乡村绿地上胡闹了。对。这可能是同一种想法。但有趣的是，汤姆，杰弗里·博伊考特从来都不是一个会贬低自己成就的人。不，这倒也是。这倒也是。但李·米勒，人们去找她并对她说：我听说你在二战中是一位伟大的摄影师。我真的很想看看你的底片。
I'd like to see the old pictures. And she says, they're all gone. They're all destroyed, which is not true. They're hidden away. And actually, she dies of cancer in 1977. She's 70 years old. And at that point, she is pretty much completely forgotten. I mean, her death is not a news story at all. And then her son basically decides to rescue her from obscurity and he finds 60 000 negatives in a box in the attic and he's like what oh my god and then he writes this biography in 1985 in which he says you know what a tremendous person she was an interesting life yeah his book really rescues her
我想看看那些老照片。而她说：它们都不见了。它们全被毁了。但这并不是真的。它们被藏了起来。事实上，她在1977年死于癌症。她享年70岁。而那时，她基本上已经被彻底遗忘了。我的意思是，她的死根本算不上什么新闻。然后她的儿子基本上决定将她从默默无闻中拯救出来，他在阁楼的一个箱子里发现了6万张底片，他当时想：什么？天哪！然后他在1985年写了这本传记，在书中他说，你知道她是一个多么了不起的人，有着多么有趣的人生啊。是的，他的书真正拯救了她，
and creates her creates the lee miller there's i mean there is a small kind of lee miller industry now and understandably so because she because she's a terrific photographer. And it's a great story because she's a woman. I think that's a really important part of the story, that she is a pioneering woman in a conflict that is seen almost entirely as a men's war, isn't it? Yeah. Quite wrongly.
塑造了她，塑造了李·米勒。我的意思是，现在有一个小型的“李·米勒产业”，这是可以理解的，因为她是一位出色的摄影师。这是一个很棒的故事，因为她是一个女性。我认为这是故事中非常重要的一部分，作为一个在一个几乎被完全视为男性战争的冲突中开拓先河的女性，不是吗？是的。完全没错。
But also the sense that her photographs, I mean, give you as vivid a sense as you can have in visual form of the horrors of the concentration camps and the heart of the Nazi darkness. Yeah. I mean, when did the photographs you took of that start to be associated with her name? Golly, I would say not until the 80s. Right. So the same. Yeah, I think it's the same thing.
但同样重要的是，她的照片——我的意思是，以视觉形式最生动地展现了集中营的恐怖和纳粹黑暗的核心。是的。我的意思是，她拍摄的那些照片是什么时候开始与她的名字联系在一起的？天哪，我觉得直到80年代才开始。没错。所以也是一样。是的，我觉得是一样的。
I think you can't overestimate how much her name had disappeared and she had colluded in that you know she wanted to lock all that part of her away there's a kind of self-loathing there i think which is actually part of the tragedy really she's the kind of the female ernest hemingway that that that idea of the american Of the American who has been part of Parisian life before the war, who then rolls into liberated Paris and is making it into art. I mean, she's doing that in the way that Ernest Hemingway, because he's Ernest Hemingway, is famous for doing. So it's all, as you say, it's kind of wonderful that her attempt to sabotage her own reputation has been redeemed. So she's got the film now. Lee. It is called Lee, yes.
我觉得怎么高估她的名字被淡忘的程度都不为过，而且她自己也合谋了这一点。你知道的，她想把她人生的那一面全部锁起来。我觉得这里面有一种自我厌恶，这其实也是悲剧的一部分。她就像是女性版的欧内斯特·海明威，那种美国人的概念——那个在战前参与过巴黎生活，随后又开进获得解放的巴黎并将其转化为艺术的美国人。我的意思是，她所做的事，正是欧内斯特·海明威因身为欧内斯特·海明威而闻名遐迩的事。所以这一切，正如你所说，她试图破坏自己声誉的企图最终得到了救赎，这真是太美妙了。所以她现在有了这部电影——《李》。是的，它就叫《李》。
So that's the story of Lee Milliton. And we love a female protagonist on The Rest is History, don't we? We absolutely do. Nothing more. Especially one with songs. With songs, yeah. So we like photography, we like song. We're all about the arts.
这就是李·米勒的故事。而在《历史其余部分》节目中，我们就是喜欢女性主角，对吧？我们绝对喜欢。没有比这更喜欢的了。尤其是带有歌曲的主角。带有歌曲，对。所以我们喜欢摄影，我们喜欢歌曲。我们全心投入艺术。
And the good news for everybody is if you've enjoyed this on monday we will be back with a story of possibly the only person in world history more glamorous than lee miller but arguably the most famous female protagonist of the whole 20th century a woman whose life became synonymous with her country's political history. And that is the story of Eva Perón, Evita. And I have to say, it will feature, I don't know what the word is. I'm trying to, I'm groping for the word. It will feature performances by our very own Tom Holland. So on that bombshell, that was the story of Lee Miller. Next week, Evita.
对每个人来说好消息是，如果你喜欢这个节目，周一我们将带着一个故事回归，主角可能是世界历史上唯一一个比李·米勒更迷人的人，可以说也是整个20世纪最著名的女性主角，一个其一生与其国家的政治历史划上等号的女性。这就是埃娃·裴隆（贝隆夫人）的故事。而且我必须说，节目中将会有——我不知道该用什么词。我正在搜寻这个词。节目中将会包含我们自己的汤姆·霍兰德的表演。伴随着这个重磅炸弹，这就是李·米勒的故事。下周，贝隆夫人。
Thank you all for listening and goodbye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢大家收听，再见。拜拜。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。